this is Jocko podcast number 195 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening good evening how much how much
is enough I mean how much does a person
have to give before they can say that
they've given enough I think that answer
is different for different people there
are some people that don't give very
much at all maybe they give just enough
to be called a participant at best and
some people don't even get there they
aren't even in the game but then if you
go to the other end of the spectrum
there are other people who give and give
and give and make sacrifice after
sacrifice and that still isn't enough
they remain ready and willing to give
even more to make more sacrifices
sacrifices that many of us can't even
comprehend and then they look up and say
what else can I do
these are rare people and it's an honor
to have one of those people here with us
tonight one of those people who has
served with honor deployed repeatedly to
war zones in Iraq and Afghanistan a man
who suffered devastating wounds lost
both of his legs but that didn't stop
him he never felt sorry for himself
instead he used the pain to make himself
stronger and tougher and better
and he represented America in the
Paralympic Games bringing home the
bronze medal for rowing he wrote a bike
across America from Maine to California
to raise money for veteran causes but
that still wasn't enough so to raise
even more money and raise more awareness
for veterans charities he ran 31
marathons in 31 days and yes you heard
that correctly 31 marathons in 31 days
but he decided that he still hadn't
given enough and after his all this all
these accomplishments his service in the
Marine Corps he still wants to serve so
now he's taking on another challenge he
is running for the 10th congressional
seat in his home state of Virginia which
it might not be the toughest battle that
he's ever fought but it will certainly
or almost certainly could be the
nastiest but you know what he is game of
course his name is Rob Jones he's a
marine he's a wounded warrior he's an
Olympian he's an inspiration to everyone
that's ever met him he's been on this
podcast twice before number 92 and
number 116 so if you haven't listened to
those go back and do so but if you have
well here he is
once again my brother Rob Jones Rob
welcome back man uh you know I would say
that I've been asked that several times
haven't you given enough and I always
say it has it's not gonna be enough
until six Marines carry me in a coffin
put me in the ground in Arlington so I'm
gonna keep doing it so what led you to
make this decision to make this
political run know what what what the
hell happened
because let's face it signing up for
politics that that is like signing up
for just extreme punishment mental
punishment of people coming after you
all the time people don't care about
your you know the way it affects you the
way it affects your family I mean it
gets crazy in politics so what was it
that made you say to yourself okay you
know what it's time for me to do this
yeah you know I've just noticed over the
last few years the deteriorating
environment in in Congress in the
federal government and I just saw that
we need leaders there and the only way
we're gonna get leaders there is if
leaders step up and they put themselves
into that arena take the risk of you
know being under fire from these people
you know kind of harkens back to I think
I talked about this last time when I
taught I talked about proof the lane
kind of how I was uh you know when you
when you searching for IEDs you have to
go out there and you have to step on the
ground and make sure that there's not an
IEE D there so you just kind of step on
it and if it blows up well guess what
there's Nighy d there if it doesn't you
get to take another step and what I
learned from that is that in Afghanistan
there's every every single day and Iraq
- every single day there are times
countless times where somebody has to
step forward and do the dangerous thing
do the difficult thing for the good of
everybody else and life is no different
and you know politics is no different
somebody has to step forward and take
that risk enter into the arena if we
want to see meaningful change so you
know in with respect to what you said
I'm just trying to continue my service
in that way and have the best impact I
can yeah well that's definitely a
different kind of minefield but it's a
minefield being your Stephanie to
and I think one of the things in you and
I were talking about this earlier
when I talk to people and I talk to I I
do pretty good in talking to people from
all different kind of political
viewpoints but one thing that I I've
seen and I think this has a lot to do
with kind of where we've gotten to this
completely divisive culture in politics
is that people lack humility like the
normal person that years ago would have
said oh well you know let me hear you
out now that person a normal person you
can talk to them and they they're they
lack humility to say you know what maybe
this person has a viewpoint that makes
some kind of sense maybe there's some
portion instead of thinking you know
what I am 100 percent right am i my
political viewpoint is 100 percent right
which means that your political
viewpoint is 100 percent 100 percent
wrong there's no value in anything that
you're gonna say you're 100% wrong and
I'm 100 percent right and that's the the
line is drawn it's and it's not even
like you owe of the line gets drawn the
line is drawn that and it starts with
hey I'm 19 years old or 26 years old or
38 years old and everything that I
believe is a hundred percent right and
that means everyone else is 100 percent
wrong unless you agree with me if you
agree with me a hundred percent you're
okay
by the way you've seen it on both sides
somebody if somebody makes a step
outside of the traditional views of the
left or the traditional views of the
right these are people that are on the
left or on the right they get shredded
by their own side because everyone's
attitude is I am 100 percent right you
don't know anything yeah I mean and well
we have to remember we have to be aware
of what the humility piece is that
nobody actually knows for sure
nobody does yeah we have evidence we
have theories but we don't know what's
gonna happen when we pass you know some
legislation and you can see that over
the course of the entirety of our
country's history
we pass the lever like oh this is this
is what its gonna do it's gonna do this
this and this pass the bill and then
that that and that happens you're like
Oh unintended consequences there's no
way to predict it so we have to go in
there with the best knowledge that we
can and all the preparation that we can
but you know keep in mind that we don't
actually know everything and we also
have to remember that that person that
disagrees with you they just they're
just coming from a different perspective
from you you know they you have to what
it really boils down to is you both want
the same thing I think usually if you
disagree with somebody you both want you
know the American people to have the
best life they can and have the most
meaningful lives they can you just want
to go about it in a different way and so
as long as you can maintain that
attitude like this person really they
want the best for these people and then
you that's how you can kind of just
disagree with them in a civil manner
mm-hmm what was the who put the idea in
your head how did that that how did
someone plant the seed did you sit in
there watching TV or watching of
somebody speak and you were like no I
got to get in this game yeah you know it
was just uh yeah popped into my head
like a lot of these other crazy ideas
that I have you know he was out one time
and and you know a lot of it has to do
with I thought of the idea initially
when I was training for the month of
marathons so you know kind of always
trying to think ahead of you know what's
the next thing gonna be what's the next
thing gonna be and I didn't do the month
marathons to prepare me for for this it
was this kind of an idea that I had like
maybe after the month of marathons has
done maybe I'll you know take the next
step and try and do a little bit more
and I'll try and run for Congress and so
I thought of that the idea then and then
I kind of you know I I was doing other
things I ran them on the marathons came
back still didn't really know what to do
or whether or not it was possible and
then after the 2018 election I texted a
buddy that I had from from the hospital
named Brian mast he's a double above
knee amputee and I just he ran in
Florida for re-election he won so I sent
a text saying congratulations on on
winning and he said send me something
saying love to have you up here let's
talk and I was like you know what I
actually am I have been thinking about
going that route he brought me into his
office and kind of gave me a rundown of
you know what it takes and what you got
to do and he set me up with his
consultants and they talked to me a
little bit and like you know what maybe
I I think I can do this so he kind of
gave me the belief that it was gonna be
possible that's awesome
alright let let me do this let me dig
into this a little bit because from the
outside what it looks like when we see
people entering the political arena it's
like all of a sudden they just kind of
magically appear right well what
actually happens you know when you talk
to your friend when you talk to these
consultants and people start looking at
you as a potential candidate what does
all that look like behind the scenes
behind the weather they call the sausage
maker yeah right usually eat the sausage
but you don't know what's going on
behind the scenes what what's going on
behind the scenes there yeah so I think
the way that I'm kind of in a unique
position where I'm friends with Brian
and he already had some folks that you
know consultant on his campaign that
were close friends of his and they had
experience you know they worked on
previous campaigns they had a lot of
experience they got him elected but I
think the vast majority of the time you
you know you approach a consult there's
a system you know it's a position you
you do campaign consulting that's your
business so that's how they make their
money
they make their money through campaign
come yeah yeah so it's a business and
there's you know there's consultants all
over the place for everything you want
to do in the campaign we're getting
elected so you know in some cases it
might just be the consultant you know
they just want to paycheck they think
they can you know get a paycheck the
thing they can try and help you but in a
lot of the cases in the case here is I
think they look at you know whether or
not you have a good story whether or not
you they think you can get elected and
then they kind of believe in you as well
and so I think when they saw me and I
kind of told him about myself they said
okay here's a good story that we think
can get traction and then the guys just
you know he just seems like he's going
to be as selfless individual and he'd be
good in Congress and so those two kind
of things combined I think in this
particular case but
you know that being said there's a
dichotomy of course on Jocko podcast
where there might be you know some
people that they're just in it for the
Paycheck to the this is their
consultants are just in it for the
paycheck sometimes not or they can be
yeah I think can be I think the vast
majority of the time you know they they
want to get behind somebody they believe
in what kind of what kind of process did
they put you through for vetting you I
mean like you said okay the interview
they know they have a good story your
stories kind of public so it's not
really hard to figure out yeah did they
get you alright we're gonna do a Q&A
with you we're gonna hammer you with
question did you all that kind of thing
gig simulator yeah a little bit I well I
met with Brian and then you know so
obviously he vouched for me so these two
guys that are his friends and ran his
campaigns they I don't think they really
needed to vet me too much more after
that after Brian vouch for me but we did
meet up and we talked a little bit and I
didn't even honestly I didn't even know
if they were gonna help me or not I
thought they were just kind of answering
a few questions that I had but then
after that they they said yeah we wanna
we want to help you run your campaign
and so yeah I think it's just getting a
feel it's getting to know somebody
getting if it's like you know hiring
somebody for a job you get to know who
they are and they just decide if they
want to work with you or not and you
know I'm lucky enough that they decided
they did and so then so then what what
happens next
yeah so I had a big plan preparation I
mean imagine yeah they want the
announcement to be a big deal right yeah
so so how did that all that go down yeah
so I think I decided you know I
committed to it and we started setting
things in motion yeah probably in April
or something like that earlier in the
year and they said okay so we're gonna
do an announcement and so that's kind of
a good way to get pressed and gets your
name out there it's all about this
getting people knowing who you are and
knowing your story so they can decide
whether or not they think that you're a
person that they can support so part of
that is making this big announcement
because you get a lot of press coverage
when you announce officially so we kind
of planned this out you make a video and
you prepare press and you do a little
bit of practice with you know answering
some of the questions you
get an announcement day but mostly
assisted by getting kind of the
sausage-making stuff in place - you got
a fight you have - there's all sorts of
rules about you know but the FEC the
federal federal election committee or
Commission or whatever that's some
really crazy we're all sorts of rules so
next thing you do is you kind of you
hire a compliancy guy I was gonna say
Ally a team like somebody that knows how
these things work and then you kind of
prepare the paperwork to file and then
you get all these you kind of get your
apparatus in place so once you announce
boom boom it's like an assault so some
of those rules that you have to be
compliant with like you can only take a
certain amount of donations right I mean
what is and they have to come from
certain places yeah so individuals can
only donate $2,800 per election and then
if there's a primary and a general
election so that's fifty six hundred
dollars per election cycle but if a
person donates $5,600 now I can only use
twenty eight hundred that for the
primary and then the other twenty eight
hundred I can use in the general
election there's all sorts of rule and
then you can't take money from
corporations
unless there's you can take money from a
pack of political action committee they
can only donate ten thousand and then
there's things called super PACs that
are kind of their own entity you can't
talk with them they can support you but
you can't talk directly with them so you
can't like plan things out with them but
they can kind of pick up on what you're
doing in your commercials in your
advertisements and they can kind of
Intuit what they should do to help your
campaign but you can't work directly
with them so yeah there's also and then
usually what you'll do is you'll fly me
out and you'll pay for a really really
nice hotel you're talking about when
you're talking about you you're saying
Jaakko podcast John come on before it's
okay yeah yeah we fly you out here yeah
and pay for your own real nice dinner or
what
but since I'm coming and I'm talking
about being a political candidate if I
want if you if I wanted you to pay for
the four of my travel out here then
you'd have to do like some kind of
in-kind donation paperwork and all sorts
of stuff so yeah there's all these
different rules so you kind of have to
have somebody that you can send an email
to really equipments can we can we do
this and they say you probably shouldn't
or they and they handle the the filing
of the paperwork and they do all that
and they handle all my donations that
come in so there's so many rules of
donations so all the donations if it's a
cheque they go down to this guy where he
is he reviews it make sure you have all
the stuff like over two hundred dollars
people have to report their employment
information and that kind of thing and
then so he makes sure you have all the
stuff and say okay this is a valid
donation we donate that and if one comes
in without the right stuff things like
this is invalid and you can't have it
how big is the staff that you have I
mean this sounds like I mean a decent
sized operation yeah I mean it's and
right now it was kind of a skeleton crew
for the most part I have my consultants
who have been with me you know since uh
before I even announced we have the
compliance guy we have digital
consultants that kind of do websites and
they kind of handle some of the digital
fundraising stuff and then I have an
individual person fundraiser so there's
somebody that knows has a lot of
personal connections as experience
raising money you know for political
campaigns and other stuff so I have her
and then she kind of helps me raise with
the raising money and then I also have
the compliance guy and then eventually
you kind of bring on more and more
people like a campaign manager and as
time goes on but yeah so you kind of
right now we have a skeleton crew and
then we're just gonna keep building and
building and and they're obviously
raising money is is unfortunately that's
basically how you get elected I mean in
a way it's it's got to be a giant
percentage of the mechanism that gets
you acted so if you don't get if you
don't raise enough money you don't even
get the platform to
say what for people to hear what it is
that you're gonna do what you're gonna
say yeah or what your beliefs are yeah
so you kind of have to get this money
raising machine moving yeah so it's more
it's more more for some people less for
other people important so the better
story you have the less money you're
gonna need to get your story out there
and you know I kind of have an advantage
where people have kind of heard of me
you know
yeah people aren't coming up to me every
day and you know asking Who I am or
anything but when somebody here's the
guy that ran thirty-one marathons like
oh yeah I know that guy
and then so I can kind of put the face
to that to that name but yeah so the the
big part of it is people knowing that
you're running knowing you exist knowing
enough about you to decide whether or
not they want to vote for you and so you
have to look at how we'll help you how
do people get their information you get
it through watching TV they get it
through doing through reading the paper
they're going online podcasts you know
things of that nature Facebook Ads
things like that and so all those things
cost money so if you want to you're not
going to go up to you know my district
has eight hundred thousand people in it
and if I went every single house for ten
minutes that's what eight million
minutes there's this not that many
minutes and so you have you should have
run you're 31 but yes I was like how do
people get their information and that's
that's the way they do it all those
things they cost money and in the DC
area especially they cost a lot of money
and then in order to get your face and
name out there at the most optimum time
the most efficient time costs even more
money if you want to have your add on
you know during Fox News or whatever in
the morning that cost a lot more money
so yeah so unfortunately it's one of
those things that you have to raise the
money in order to just to get your name
out there so people know you exist so
what is that what is the process from
here on out what does it look like I
mean take me all the way well as to the
best of your knowledge
what happens next so your your obviously
you spend the next however many months
raising money to get this thing going
forward what does the rest of this time
look like yeah so you know big
milestones along the way yes bring you
to Election Day victory yeah the money
raising now so kind of your first
quarter that you raise is kind of a bit
of an indicator like if you've raised
enough money in the first quarter that a
lot of people kind of use that as a
gauge on how much of a chance you have
mm-hmm and so that's kind of something
so you want to get you want to have a
good raise in your first quarter when
did your first quarter start July first
so it kind of goes on the fiscal
quarters okay so July 1st to September
30th so they're coming up to it and then
I've kind of had a little bit of a
disadvantage because we did our
announcement on the same be that I got
wounded which was July 22nd kind of to
make the announcement a little bit more
special right and so we can exert gave
up in like three weeks yeah and so yeah
so that's one milestone and then while
you're doing that you're raising money
raiser money and then it's how's it
going the first quarter right now it's
gonna be it's been a little bit
difficult because there's a lot of
different factors it's summertime so
people are you know on vacation there's
also a local election in Virginia coming
up so a lot of people are kind of more
focused on that they're not really
focusing on next year yet understandably
so and then at the same time I don't I'm
not a politician you know I have no
political apparatus before this and a
lot of people that run for office at
this level you know they've ran for
county seat then they run for state seat
and they run another state seat so they
have you know people that have donated
to them consistently over the years so
they can kind of go back to these people
over and over again every time they have
an election mm-hmm so they have those
people that have already donates they
can raise money kind of quick I don't
have that yeah so I kind of have to
build that donor base from scratch the
other thing that I must imagine is a
little bit weird is like learning how to
ask for money yeah I mean it's uh I know
I feel weird asking to anyone for help
in anything right the guy would rather
just do something myself than have to
say
can help maybe that's an ego thing a
little bit of yeah had or anyone's help
maybe it's an ego thing of hey don't
want to give that person up the little
one up on me yeah you know yeah I don't
want it that's but uh but also you know
it's just like being self-sufficient
right yeah and not wanting to ask for a
handout I mean even when we started this
podcast there was the whole the whole
what is it like donation thing was out
there right it was out there was kind of
a thing and you and there was a lot of
people that that's how they were running
their podcasts was by just taking
donations and we we actually still have
like a little thing where you can you
can don't look at have something on the
website you can donate through PayPal or
something like that then we've had a
couple people that have like that that
have done that but we've probably talked
about it twice or whatever like barely
ever because to me it feels kind of
weird to say yeah hey hey give me some
money right and in honestly when when we
first started trying to when we were
first talking about how we would get
money to buy what would do to support
what we're doing I said you know well
maybe we just make some t-shirts you
know and you're like yeah we can make
you sure it's all day cool because that
way we're you know we're not just saying
give me something yeah we're saying hey
you buy this thing and it helps support
yes so you gotta you had to overcome the
the idea of I'm gonna ask people for
money yeah it's extremely it's very very
yeah so what you do first is you go to
friends and family and you say look
thinking of it that's another one of the
rules you can't say before you announce
you can't say you're actually running
yet you can only say I'm strongly
considering running for Congress would
you donate if I do decide to do this
even if you've already you know decided
that you're going to you can't actually
say it because then you technically you
have to file so what you can say is I'm
usually so you go your mom your dad your
close friends and family I'm strongly
considering right because I'm laugh
because in my family those are last
people UBS and money I don't ask but you
know that's not happening we're getting
zero first two calls were my dad and
then my mom yeah so they were yeah they
were supportive and then you just kind
of slowly call through your friends and
family like every phone every phone
number you have in your phone you like
so I started with kind of people that I
talk to you regularly obably would you
donate and they say yes and then you
kind of just go through and that's kind
of weird too cos now you're like asking
the question but not even close yes now
you're gonna go back if you have to go
that's the purpose of saying that what's
the purpose just to do you go back to
your consultants and say hey listen I'm
getting up I'm getting a 50% feedback
the people will donate yeah well the
thing about asking people for donations
is I had it I had a good buddy named
Frank that I called him all right I
texted him or called him or whatever
beforehand I said I'm gonna think about
running for Congress will you don't he's
like oh yeah definitely I will
definitely donate and then I'm saying
okay what we're trying to do I get
everybody to donate on Monday we want
everybody donate on Monday because we
want to raise a bunch of money like on
day one so it's kind of a thing in the
political sphere you'll see like I think
recently a couple of the Democratic
presidential candidates they announced
and they said oh and we raised hundreds
of thousands of dollars on day one oh
they think that's really cool and it's
kind of a big deal
and so I say trying to get everybody
donate on Monday July 22nd you know if I
run or whatever so then my phone I gave
my fundraiser all the text messages that
I contacted she sent them all a text on
Monday reminding him here's the link and
then this guy Frank he didn't donate and
then so I called him again you know a
week later like hey just wanted to
remind you you know I've been ounce now
raising money and he calls me back a
couple weeks later and he says okay I
finally donated and I said and he wrote
he uh yeah and he runs the rowing
program for UVA the men's rowing program
and so he has to get a lot of donations
I said so well you got any uh got any
tips for me on raising money you know
how to ask for money I'm not very good
at it you said listen you got to
remember I'm a close friend and it took
me three weeks and three reminders to
donate to you
so you hit somebody up the first time
and they want to know they they they
want to support you but you just hit
them you know when they're about to get
in the car or you know their take
dropping the kids off at school or
something like that and they just forget
you know and so you gotta remind them
again and then so you kind of have to
make sure you hit them at the right time
where they're okay I'm just sitting
around watching TV or whatever I'm
eating dinner I can do it right now
so you kind of have to just keep
following up with people so you you uh
friends of family first
and then once you get through all that
then you start kind of calling people
that have donated previously so you kind
of you can get these lists sitting here
trying to think if you if what you hit
me up I didn't notice if you hit me up I
think you said hey I'm gonna run or I'm
thinking about Congress maybe I could
come back on the podcast and I was like
oh absolutely yes
yeah I think I don't think you actually
hit me up for the cash though I didn't
hit you up for the cash because
friendship capital like I don't like a
leadership capital okay yeah I figure
you're kind of already helping me out so
you've helped me out so much already
with having me on you know before the
month marathon's after the month of
marathons and all that stuff and now
you're gonna help me out again with this
podcast and I just kind of figure you
know I don't want to ask too much of you
well right on but you're not going to
get anything if you don't have remember
too that you have you have to ask even
though it's uncomfortable so yeah that
you start product can you sell a t-shirt
and and use that the profits from that I
don't know I don't I'm not sure I'd have
that we're not personal money like yours
you're rich politicians in yes man no
can self-fund as much as you want you
can donate to your campaign as much as
as much as you want but if you're doing
I don't you know I don't have enough
money anyway so it wouldn't really be a
drop in the bucket for me to spend all
our savings oh and carrots yeah it's not
enough carrots to pay for this we just
start getting eggs so maybe that'll be
you know something that we can add to it
but yes white simply just don't have
enough money but yeah there's some
there's some people that take mortgages
their homes and they kind of loaned the
campaign 200-300 thousand dollars and
then they get paid back after they
really start raising money I can't do
that either because I don't have a
mortgage on my home because it was given
to me by a wounded veteran charity so
there's no mortgage and I can't take out
a mortgage for five years there's a part
of our contract but yeah so you ask the
people close to you they donate and then
you start kind of going through these
lists of people that have donated to
campaigns before they're politically
active a lot of the times they have a
little bit more cash to spare you start
calling them but that's unpleasant too
because a lot of the times it's just
cold calls mm and you go you know you
have this year this is the yeah this is
me so what my fundraiser she just
basically just sends me call sheets so
she gets these lists of it's all
publicly available if they donate over a
certain amount she just goes online they
do they donated to this other Republican
candidate or this other Democratic
candidate so they might like you so you
just kind of and there's a bunch of
phone numbers on there and a lot of the
times it doesn't work or it's like a
main number to their business and you
kind of have to go in and go into the
directory and call it and you call them
up and you just go you know do your
little 20-second spiel how many of these
phone calls have you made oh and it's
like my schedule is nine to eleven
campaign fundraising phone calls work
out at eleven eat lunch at twelve one
two three make phone calls
what are you doing from 4:30 in the
morning until 9:00 4:30 and more until
9:00 usually a 4:30 to 6:30 cutting
little sawing logs and then seven is
usually when I start I'll start reading
they're all start doing some writing
kind of fleshing out my thoughts on
things and then between 7:00 and 9:00
because you can't call people before
9:00 o'clock it's so so so 9:00 to 11:00
you're making phone calls and you said
from 1:00 to 3:00 you're also making
phone yeah if I have just hammering
through a list yeah so my fund raisers
will still send me 20 25 at a time and
these less than you just kind of look at
it this way guys what's the contact rate
Mary love you make a hundred calls how
many people do you talk to
I'd say maybe 10 like directly what I
call 10% yeah that I the the chance of
you have of me picking up a phone yeah
number I don't recognize zero yeah it's
zero and a lot of time what you do is
you call and the vast majority of the
time you're calling their place of work
and so they have an assistant and so you
have to kind of do you know you have to
you have to kind of craft a little
script almost do that gets them to that
kind of intrigues them and it has to be
short because it can't be too long a lot
when I first started out I was doing
let's hear a 30-second okay let's hear
it all right so I'll ring ring ring I'll
call echo ring ring ring hello
oh hi this is Rob Jones I'm calling for
mr. Charles this is him oh hi mr.
Charles my name is Rob Jones I'm a
wounded marine from Middleburg Virginia
and I'm calling today because I'm
running for Congress in Virginia's 10th
district and this hoping you might have
a few minutes to speak with me about my
campaign to see if you might be willing
to support me yeah and that's what I say
yeah pretty straightforward that's it
yeah so I kind of and it's been kind of
and your fundraiser they're kind of good
at that so they can advise you on what
to say and so I cut when I first started
out I kind of had like this minute long
monologue they're like hello hi I'm Rob
Jones and I ran 31 marathon in 31 days
and I did all this stuff and then like
by the end of it you know it's they
haven't spoken in like a minute and a
half
well you gotta bring that down when a
win leaf and I wrote extreme ownership
then we did our first event that the
book was at and it was a big event or
it's like maybe a thousand to fifteen
hundred people there and we got done we
got offstage and they had a bunch of
books for us to sell and people weren't
gonna buy and then they could we could
sign them and as soon as we got off
stage it was like mayhem everyone was
really fired up and here's this brand
new book and the big message you just
come from us and so the the end they got
the two little tables for us to sign on
there's a stack of books for us to to
give to the people and
the very first person and you know let
life like the joke is that life is like
a nice person and I'm not and so the
first and immediately as I looked at the
line this was you know one of those this
is like one of the few things that I'm
naturally gifted at like looking at a
scenario and kind of figuring out really
quick what needs to happen to to get
this done so I see people lined up and I
say to myself alright I need to be
signed in these books as fast as humanly
possible so I immediately start signing
the extreme ownership book just own it
Jaakko that's that's all I'm right yeah
so I get like two or three people
hey I you know nice to meet you Jim Jim
own it Jaco boom hannett's laughs boom
next person I get through five or six
people and and all of a sudden there's
all there's a there's a there's a
roadblock right next to me his name is
lave Babbitt and he's such a nice guy
that you know he says hey Jim how you
doing worried about you from any other
persons I come from wherever I'm from
Maryland ah you know I went to Naval
Academy up there
Annapolis man what a beautiful what do
you do for a living and and he's having
a legit conversation and then he's right
and you know Jim so good to talk to
another person that you know grew up in
the fine state of Maryland and I
appreciate the support that y'all gave
us when I was up there going to Naval
Academy and I hope that everything goes
well with your business appreciate it
leading wind and man it took him it was
like it took him by the time he I had
handed him the the you know 17th book
and he wasn't done with his first one he
just he started writing later and so but
yeah you know it's like the the the the
ability to really be nice in a situation
like that
yeah is a little bit tougher and also
you know people but you don't waste
people's time you know what I mean yeah
you got to get to the point like you
said you got to get you got to get your
at least the initial message of hey this
is who I am and this is what I'm doing
and do you want to talk about that a
little bit yeah and I it's it's a
strange balance because I want to I want
to keep it short but also say something
that makes them give me the benefit of
the doubt
so it's kind of figuring out what that
is and I decided saying I'm a wounded
marine running for Congress that was
kind of a good balance of that well
that's a big statement right that's a
doer in the Marine Corps
you obviously have served you have made
sacrifices for your country already and
now you're willing to serve more that's
a pretty big that's that's a short
statement but it's also it carries
there's a lot of meaning behind it
there's a lot of weight behind it yeah
okay so I'm still sitting here thinking
myself from a efficiency perspective you
don't have some other three people that
are dialing through and being like okay
Rob we got a live one boom in hand and
you the phone not really I mean
sometimes my fundraiser will have
relationships some people and she'll say
I've already talked to this guy just but
you just got to call him and talk to him
for a couple minutes and he's probably
the donate but yeah I guess you know the
way that it works is people probably
aren't gonna talk to you if you don't
call them directly yeah I'm gonna tell
you what don't ever I'll donate to your
campaign don't give my number to any of
those lists I don't want anyone else
call me how much you donate you just put
Victory's phone numbers or put yeah you
gotta put a phone number at some point
and I'm gonna try and tell this without
without dropping any dimes on anyone or
anything but anyways there was a an
organization and it's not really a
charity organization but somehow I had
donated money to this organization a
long time ago and so they would call me
consistently all the time
and when they would call my house I
would put them on speakerphone so my
whole family could be entertained by
what I would say but anyways they called
one time and they say oh this we're
looking for mr. wink I said yeah this is
now this is Baba blah blah blah and
we're you know it's fundraising time
again and we're we're looking to up the
numbers this year and this is one I got
our own speakerphone and I don't forget
the years it was but the girl says and
I'm looking at your records right now
and it looks like the last time you
donated was eight years ago you donated
ten dollars
and I was like yeah I said why don't you
call me in another eight years and we'll
react that fit like I would never give
out anybody's phone number but if they
don't if they donate and they report it
theirs and that's how you get it yeah so
that's that that's kind of where people
are coming from with they get donation
calls all the time and I'm just another
guy so you have to figure out how to
make yourself unique and get through
that kind of guardedness in the very
beginning that you know they're they're
automatically probably gonna say no you
know I get this is the 50th call I've
gotten call them at work and these
people a lot of the times you know
they're a little bit wealthier so it's
not like they just got all their wealth
by sitting around watching Netflix you
know they are working they're working
hard so yeah you kind of have to figure
out a way and all the times it'll be
I'll talk to an assistant and then
she'll say well no they're not available
or they're not here because they're
working I'm gonna leave a message with
her or I'll leave a voicemail on their
phone and then I give it a week if I
have an email address for them I'll send
up a follow-up email and you can be a
little bit more of a boast and an email
so I kind of like that where I'll I can
kind of mention the 31 marathons and be
a little bit more verbose they're
sending a follow-up email if they don't
reply to that then I'll call them again
you just kind of have to you have a
spreadsheet of people you call and
you're like call them okay I call this
person ten days ago so today's almost
weird to me is you could call a
billionaire who goes oh I absolutely
want to support you I got your back 100%
I was in the Marine Corps I was wounded
as well and in Korea or in Vietnam and
you got my support and do all you can
get from his weight loss yeah exactly
really but yeah in some other elections
like in state elections if a billionaire
likes you you can give you a billion
dollars if you want but federal bucks
and you can't do that
so yeah that's it's and it's tough so
you got a call and call and call and
call and then you got to do stuff you
know to get your name out there and at
some point will it beat will someone
else start making calls for you not
really I mean so
Brian who continues help it helped me in
a lot of different ways he'll make calls
like he has he has donated so that he
goes doing so lately he's been making a
few calls to their donors to his donors
and saying you know let me tell you
about this guy Rob Jones will you
consider talking to him and they say
yeah sure have them call me so then I
call them so in a way yeah
and then if yeah I mean if somebody
knows somebody that they think would be
interested in speaking to me and
donating to my campaign they'll call
them but a lot of these people nobody
knows and so and a lot of the times my
fund raisers shall set me up with people
that are more likely to see thinks are
more likely doing it like I've called
several Marines yeah you know or other
veterans and yeah and so they have that
connection with me immediately because
we're both veterans so they're more
willing to talk to me it seems to me
like it would be a good idea to get
someone else to call
for two reasons number one efficiency of
your time but number two it's kind of
like it's easier for someone else to
brag about you than it is for you to
brag about yourself yeah yeah just call
up and say hey how you doing my name is
Jocko will encana I'm actually not
calling for myself I'm calling for a
great friend of mine that is a former
Marine he was wounded in Afghanistan and
he's actually not done serving yet he's
running for Congress here in the great
state of Virginia and I was wondering if
you could maybe help out or interested
in supporting what he's doing like it
seems like that would be kind of a good
way to do it and no I agree with you I
you have to have you know outside the
box ideas like that because the instinct
is well because my first instinct
minutes oh that's awesome that you're
doing it yourself like that really shows
like if you personally called me I'd be
more apt but then I thought about it
well maybe but someone else calling me
and saying hey this guy's running he's a
great guy it's sort of a it seems like
that would be helpful as well I'm not a
manager so the consultants hey back off
everyone here
out of me right now no I tell Rob not to
do that yeah no I think I think the main
difference is probably that the
fundraiser kind of knows that these
people might not go for that kind of
thing but what you're talking about I
think would work great on kind of a more
of a grassroots level where you're
trying to call a lot of people and get
smaller donations and that's kind of
important too you want to get all those
donations as well oh so right now you're
going after the big hitters yeah you
kind of go like these calls they're
people that have donated you know $1,000
in the past 5,000 and that kind of thing
so those kinds of people usually
wouldn't it's so weird the way these
mechanisms work oh yeah world like this
is you you set up a system and you have
no idea like you know you said earlier
you you make laws and but you don't
actually know what they're gonna do when
they hit the books and when they start
getting enacted in the world this is one
of those things like whoever made these
laws probably or these rules or when
these rules were made people had no idea
how it was gonna turn out what it
actually what that actually translates
to in the real world yeah and one of my
favorite examples of that is going
through Officer Candidate School in
Officer Candidate School there was
things that you did in Officer Candidate
School that had no there's no possible
way that the intention of the drill
instructors was to have you doing what
you're doing one of the examples is you
get a belt buckle you get a belt buckle
that has a coating on it it's like a
shiny brass belt buckle but it's got a
coating on this shiny brass belt buckle
that cuz you know brass turns green or
whatever real quick well you get this
one that's been treated in such a way
that it never will get it just stays
shiny all the time I mean you can get
thumb prints on it if you stick your
finger over your thumbprint but you can
easily wipe it off well you cook what
you do is you have to clean these belt
buckles with brass oh until that lining
comes off completely and then you end up
with a thing that you have to constantly
polish all the time and it doesn't hold
its shine and you think yourself at some
point someone said hey make sure there's
no fingerprints on your brass belt
buckle and so people started cleaning it
and
they started cleaning it until the
actual finish was off
yeah and now this thing has become you
become a totally different game right
the game is no longer just keep your
belt buckle clean it's go completely
psycho with the with with bra so until
the thing is it's not even functional
anymore and when you get done with
alternate school you throw that thing
away because it has no purpose yeah they
didn't mean it that way
at some point somewhere along the way a
drill instructor said hey you got a
phone print make sure there's no thumb
prints on your on your belt buckle and
that it went from that over however many
3050 years to you polish all the finish
completely off that thick until it's
just pure brass you get all these weird
things that happened like that yeah and
that's what this is you know it's this
environment that's created and all of a
sudden you've got these these potential
candidates or candidates that are
running that are jumping through these
random hoops that have been built by
random laws that were that seemed to
make sense to somebody at some time yeah
well they're not entirely random but
it's they have they have you know
purposes and theories behind them they
want to prevent corruption they won't
they want you know politicians be bought
off or anything like that but then
you're never gonna think of absolutely
every single contingency that could
possibly happen and then so you have the
you know these are the rules and then
you know human beings we have these big
old brains that we can adapt to and we
people figure out you know ways to
maneuver and you know this is what you
get and then so you like okay we can't
do this and this and this and I will
they just do it a different way yeah so
you can you know you you create this the
best system you can and then you just
have to let people you know you all
obviously always try and improve upon it
but you just have to live within that
system do you guys do like like
analytics to see hey how much are we
getting from the callings there I just
feel like a door-to-door cold calling
like is just as time goes on it's like
less and less and less effective yeah
well yeah so we keep track so like
everybody that I call I put in a
spreadsheet and then I
talking I put in there the results of
the call what number I called you know
what day I called them so I can kind of
look back and then yeah so we kind of
know and so we can kind of analyze that
but kind of as you as time goes on a lot
of the times it'll get easier to raise
money because people see that you're
raising money and success breeds success
so they'll check and say oh this guy's
already raised two hundred thousand
dollars or whatever it may be
and then oh okay so he's a viable
candidate now so I'm actually gonna
donate him and another reason that's
kind of hard right now is because we
have you know there's gonna be a primary
and a lot of people don't want to
support in a primary because these
people have money they want to invest in
something that they think is going to
you know be fruitful so then there's no
way to know and so that's why you kind
of have to get your story out there you
have to kind of convinced them you know
why you're a viable candidate and why
they should support you and it's not
it's not the most pleasant thing to have
to do and it's not the easiest thing to
do but the more you do it the more I'm
kind of getting used to it now and I'd
rather ask a stranger for money than you
know ask a close friend for money for
sure yeah so then what's it okay so we
get we get through this first quarter
ends in September then what what's the
what where does the campaign go from
there do you have any idea or you just
kind of like on board for the ride I
have no I I have an idea of where it's
gonna go but yeah I'm not an expert is
my first time so at the same time as
you're raising money in these early
stages you are getting just getting out
and talking to people going to events
and it's like I've been going to
Republican committee meetings and
introducing myself like a lot of the
times they'll allow candidates to come
up in the beginning and speak for a few
minutes and just so they know you know I
introduced myself and then so you kind
of building that network of people that
know who you are and you creating a
little bit of buzz and you're meeting
people and I go out and I talk to board
of supervisors on counties and I just
kind of talk and mayors and that kind of
thing and I just say I just sit down
then what are the you know what are the
issues that people are talking about
here and Northern Virginia is always
traffic this is like number one and so I
just say well what are people talking
about it's kind of get details on that
because these people kind of know
you know they know the people on a
granular level because they're local
representatives so they can kind of tell
me and then you kind of look at that and
you can kind of see okay most of the
people are talking about this and this
and this and so you kind of get a feel
for that and then at the same time
you're doing that you're doing a lot of
you know research on policy so you got
to read up on you know all these
different issues that you're finding out
that people care about you got to figure
out you know what they are what you can
do to change them what you can do to
improve them and that kind of thing so
you're kind of doing all these things
simultaneously you just kind of go on
that trajectory raise money meet people
learn policies when's the primary for
you so Virginia is kind of unique in
that they every year they kind of decide
how they're going to select candidates
the Republican Party knows how they're
going to select their candidates so they
just recently decided that they're not
going to do a primary what they're going
to do is call it convention and so
they're going to have this convention in
the 10th district sometime next year
they haven't set a date for you it'll
probably be springtime spring maybe
early summer yet probably late spring
and what they'll do is they'll bring in
all these delegates from all over the
counties the counties send a certain
number of delegates in and what they'll
do is all the candidates that want to
try and be the the Republican candidate
they'll get up and they'll speak in
front of the delegation and then the
delegates will go vote and then if they
don't have over 50% if one person
doesn't have over 50% they'll knock off
through the bottom one or the bottom two
and they'll vote again and I'll keep
doing that and keep doing that keep
doing that and then at the end they'll
send white smoke out of the the top of
the building no but they'll have so
eventually be one person versus one
person some I'll get the majority and
then that's the person that's it right
there and how many other people are
going into the 10th District against you
do you know right right now there's one
one other guy army veteran but there's
always rumors I mean there's always
other people that you know come in and
so there's rumors about other people
that are thinking about
coming in but until they file you don't
know it says just conjecture so you now
that this just got recently decided on
the fifth so now that we have that kind
of a situation that's good and bad for
us you know I'm like Musashi I have no
preference I'll just do whatever the
system is that's what it is okay cool
we're gonna adapt to that but uh it's
good for us because it requires less
money so you don't have to go out there
and do commercials for the primary and
that kind of stuff you'll have to do a
lot of advertising you can save all your
money for the general election and when
you're running against an incumbent they
already have millions and millions and
millions of dollars so you're gonna be
coming from a from a deficit compared to
them so that's good I can kind of save a
little bit of money but it's also a
little bit more difficult because now
you have to go out and you have to kind
of you have to find out who the
delegates are and they make a list of it
but you have to kind of talk to these
delegates and you have to convince them
why you're the you know the best person
if you don't have make a good impression
on this one person well they might not
you know that's a vote loss and so
there's only so many delegates you can
talk to so yeah it's kind of pros and
cons with it but that's what we're doing
and so that's what I'm adapting to and
that's what we're gonna do gonna make
happen and that's not even we don't even
know when that's gonna happen right now
right yeah 20-point spring of 22 yeah do
you get will you be making a speech at
that thing straight up yeah yeah I think
so that's what I've been told anyway I
guess they they have to come up with all
the rules and everything of how it's
gonna work well then I guess they have
rules in place but they have to like
release them so you know I'm sure
there's you know you have to file as a
candidate and all this stuff you know at
the convention but I think what the what
the guy told me that I talked to said is
that they're gonna do it where each
person gets up and gives a stump speech
before they start voting but a lot of
the work is gonna be done before ideally
you will have all your votes before you
even ever give that speech you're gonna
do the legwork it's kind of like you
know this is actually something that Pam
says
and she's a you know four-time world
champion two-time Paralympic champion so
I should probably listen to what she
says about competing
she says the race is won not on the day
but in the months and years that you
spent training beforehand so you got to
put in the legwork talk to these
delegates and you can even convince
friends of yours to go try and be
delegates they see I kind of you know
get a team together like that move yeah
get a team together they go there and
try and become delegates they're your
friends so they'll vote for you so you
have to kind of do that legwork in order
to hopefully win the the vote before you
even give your stump speech this is uh
one of the things I was thinking about
as you know when we start talking about
politics and in your case in particular
one of the things that comes up all the
time in politics is gun control and all
those issues one of the things I was
thinking about is you're you went to
Virginia Tech mm-hm April 16th 2007
there was 32 people killed in a mass
shooting yeah were you on campus when
that happened no I was uh in my
apartment oh you were yeah I was there
my students senior year so I was there
ish but I was in an apartment off campus
I just lived there and when we got the
first reports it was kind of like they
were just saying that somebody was
roaming around campus you know shooting
people so maybe I just you know
graduated from boot camp not too long
before so I like immediate go over there
so I you know I walked over to campus to
see if I put out any kind of protection
or anything to see if I could find this
guy or whatever walked around a little
bit but you know I didn't see anybody
because you know it all was all
happening in the building it was all
over by the time I even left my
apartment and yeah so I wasn't you know
I wasn't there there you know I was
nowhere near the shooting but I was
there for the you know the aftermath and
the you know just the pain that we felt
as a community after the fact what was
the what was the atmosphere afterwards
I mean what they do with
students at school did you guys what do
you do with a you know a test you have
on on Wednesday we just have the basic
life stuff yeah this is disbelief you
know you can't believe that it happened
at all
and you can't believe that it happened
to you you know to your community and
yes it's one of those I think they you
know they they just have to give you
time they give you they give you know
gave everybody the week off then either
the school I think did a really good job
of supporting the students and in my
opinion you know they said no pressure
they actually came out and said if you
want to you don't have to finish the
semester if you don't want to you can
just cut your grades here and your
teacher your professor will you know
have a grade for you based on what
you've done to this point and you don't
have to you don't have to finish the
year if you don't want to and so they
gave him that option they had you know
support available to to anybody that was
you know was struggling with with
dealing with the situation they made
that available you know memorials it's
like there's not a whole lot you can't
the only other thing that everybody
wants you to do is go back in time and
have somebody tackle that guy you know
before he ever did anything you know not
to make it about me but the way I felt
that I felt I felt guilty that I wasn't
in the building you know that's how I
kind of felt about it like maybe I could
have been in one of those rooms and ran
out the guy and I don't know given given
people sometime you know like a lot of
people did you know there was one
professor that was a Holocaust survivor
slam the door blocked it and I think he
had his students crawl out the window or
something and he gets you know he got
killed by the by the shooter and so
that's kind of how I felt at the time
about it I wish I had been there to
maybe do something but it's mostly just
you just you know you just can't believe
it it's kind of indescribable it's an
interesting idea of giving uh when you
first said oh they gave people the
option of just taking their grade right
there or whatever it happened to be at
that time and then you
you don't have to finish the semester at
first I thought to myself yeah that's a
really good idea and then as I thought
about it sitting here as you were
talking that what what that does what
that could do to people is okay now what
are you gonna do so now what do you do
yeah you sit there and you start to do
well on this and you that seems to me
like a good idea that in practice the
best thing to do not the best thing to
do but well I think it's the best thing
to do is okay we're gonna you know we're
gonna get a week off right maybe we're
gonna get two weeks off but we're gonna
get a week off we're gonna hold
ceremonies we're gonna mourn and then
we're gonna get back to work and we're
gonna carry on and because otherwise
you're stuck with just the thoughts of
the lost day I've suffered and it's one
of those weird things and you know when
you say when you say that you that you
need to move on right it sounds like the
coldest most horrible thing that a
person could say if you if someone loses
a loved one and you look at them you say
well you know you've got to move on
right and and that's like that seems
like the most horrible and cold thing to
say yeah hey you've lost a loved one but
guess what you got to move on it that
sounds so horrible but it's it's kind of
what you need to do right I mean you
it's what you need to do you're your
loved one that you've lost that they
don't want you to sit around and mourn
for seven months while you wait for the
semester to end for summer to end and
then you go what are you gonna do during
that time period yeah and so that's a
rough thing to think about but I think
it's it's definitely one of those hard
things you have the hard conversation
that you have to have and sometimes you
have to have that conversation with
yourself is when you say to yourself or
you say to someone else you've got to
move on and it seems so cold and
heartless but at the same time it's what
you actually do have to do yeah yeah I
never actually thought about it from
that person
active in terms of you know them
allowing people to to you know cut the
semester short but you know that's a
really good point you have to have
something to do otherwise you're just
gonna sit around and just think about it
all day all the time but at the same
time you know they didn't want people's
grades to be affected by be negatively
affected by you know 450 like that so no
it's kind of see where they're coming
from for sure
tough decision to make tough decision to
make yeah I don't know you know another
thing that that's that I've definitely
thought about since you you know entered
into this arena is thinking about a
thing about Lewis Polar jr. right yeah
running for running for the House of
Representatives in the first District of
Virginia he ran as a Democrat he as we
know lost the election and he lost it to
basically a Republican kind of war hawk
yeah that had the draft deferment
multiple times so didn't go to Vietnam
but was kind of you know a war Hawk type
guy yeah and one thing that's really
interesting when you read fortunate son
is that there was all these
opportunities that Lewis Polar jr. had
to kind of start negative campaigning
against his opponent and he didn't do it
and he ran that campaign with as much
dignity and class as you as a person
could run yeah and any loss and he lost
by a big big margin to I think he lost
by like 25 percent yeah which is easy to
think about are you thinking about right
now what it looks like where where your
own personal line of hey this is too far
and I'm not gonna go there yesterday
yeah you have to maintain your moral
compass and you want I want to win but I
want to win in the way that I set out to
win I don't want to win by being
somebody that I'm not
I want to win by being the person
that I am and then if people want that
person to represent them in Congress
then I'd be honored to do that but if
the person I am the people will decide
that they don't want that in Congress
you know fair enough
I understand no hard feelings I still
love this area still love the district
this is where you get into a little
slippery slope possibility okay because
here's the question you can ask yourself
is listen I'm Rob Jones I know I could
want to do the right thing for the right
reasons in order for me to have that
possibility I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to get a little bit medieval on
some people here right yeah and and you
think okay as soon as this is over
though I'll go right back to you know
being on the moral high ground but if I
if I stay on the moral high ground this
whole time there's I might not even get
there so I need to position my like
there's a slippery slope there you say
no what I gotta make yes I got to run
this negative ad I gotta do this I gotta
make this statement about my opponent
right that stuff or or I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna get the publicity that I need
to win that's a slippery that's a
slippery slope well that's yeah that's
the gray area that a lot of elections
are won and lost in and you know maybe
we should write a book after this called
the dichotomy of politics you know and
it's just yeah you have your you know
kind of so-called default aggressive
type of opinion or position on that
default you know good guy or whatever it
may be
but then yeah you have kind of sign of
some some gray areas there where yeah if
the elections going bad and you feel
like this person is really gonna be bad
for for the country and for the district
then you might have to do something that
you wouldn't normally do but you kind of
maintain that moral compass even with
that so you take it to a certain level
and then you dial it back you don't do
it again
and you don't let it kind of slip away
and you keep doing it so you kind of
have to take every situation as it's
your own unique situation and kind of
step out and then step back step out
step back as needed
guess I think that in the end with
situations like that what it what you
have to maintain above all is you have
to maintain the truth right and if you
maintain the truth about what's
happening I think in the in the law in
the long run and oftentimes in the short
run hey if you're telling the truth
about what's going on that's what that's
when ya make you win yeah very true yeah
you can kind of go negative can say
something that's bad about the other
person but you can just say oh well this
negative ad is this person voted for
this bill that did this and that's kind
of going negative but it's not you know
you know there's something that as a
person and you're telling the truth yeah
not you're not making something that's
good that's a good that's a good way to
approach it I'll let you know how it
goes when I start having to make those
types of decisions yeah hopefully it's
so obvious that I'm going to win that I
won't even have to make those decisions
but you know and that's the other weird
thing about politics is you know I used
to think of the officers that were in
the military and most of the time much
of the time the officers that you wanted
to work for were the kind of officers
that didn't really care is not the right
word but I'm not sure how to explain it
didn't really they weren't all jazzed up
because they were an officer yeah they
were jazzed up to work with the troops
they were jazzed up to serve the country
they weren't they weren't doing it for
their own career right and it's the same
thing with politics if you think about
the type of people that you would
actually want to have in political power
one of the main reasons why you would
want them in that position is because
they would never want to be there yeah
they're the type of people that say well
they're people like you that say hey
listen this is not what I want to do but
this is kind of what I have to do this
is the void of leadership and and and
someone needs to fill that void yeah so
there's a another kind of dichotomy
there that the person that you would
actually want in that position is the
person that fundamentally in their own
heart
really want that position yeah and you
you end up with and it's sort of like in
in man search for meaning the book about
the concentration camps and he says that
the best of us didn't make it the best
of us didn't survive because the best
people in the concentration camp the
purest and most good people were the
people that said hey you take this crust
of bread instead of me hey you take I'll
step up and do this labor that's gonna
push you over the edge and make you sick
I'll give you my blanket at night
because we only have 1 4 4 4 of us and
you're the one that needs it the most
those good people they didn't survive
and that's kind of it's kind of what
happens in politics or it could very
well it happens in many cases in
politics where the person that won't
cross that line the person that doesn't
just look out for themselves first
that's the person that doesn't win
because they didn't go negative
they didn't mud sling they didn't
undermine and and they end up not
winning so this is a tough situation but
I think what's good is I think there's
more opportunity now and I think there's
a lot of things out there that level the
playing field and I think one of them is
social media right this is just like
this podcast ok you're on here you get
to tell you get to talk about people
know your story they hear it on a broad
basis you know your you got your own
social media that you can talk directly
to people and there's no filter doesn't
cost any money to put up a social media
post now does it cost money to advertise
a social media post yes it does it does
so if somebody can dump more money into
that but at least the playing field is
more level than it used to be for you to
get your voice out there and not have to
do slimy shady things to do it yeah and
then yeah with with respect to what
you're saying about you know some people
didn't survive you also have to wonder
whether or not a lot of the times are
some of the times surviving isn't always
the best thing
so if you have to do something to just
to survive and it's something that's
even worse than death then sometimes you
don't want to survive and sometimes you
can be fine with that and so it's kind
of the same thing with with political if
I have to sling mud and do all that
stuff then maybe that's maybe that's not
worth it yeah no I I totally agree
all right you wrote a little something
about leadership and it's I'm just gonna
kind of read some chunks of it here
there's a void of true leadership in
Congress he's blatantly avid evident in
all the modern forms of media print
broadcast and social it Pat it is
patently obvious that the words and
behaviors of many of our elected
representatives at all levels and in all
political parties one needn't look
further than this void to identify the
root of the rotten climate in politics
that is sickening the American public
there's a big chunk of the American
public that are sickened by that there's
a big chunk that actually just full-on
participates - yeah that's true it's
it's it's crazy I'm not - I'm not an
active participant in Facebook I mean I
have facebook and I post on Facebook but
I don't I don't get involved much in
like the personal Facebook right yeah
but I hear stories about Facebook from
people that are on it it's like a crazy
battleground yeah where people unfriend
you if you make a statement or you like
someone's political post that they don't
agree with yeah it's like crazy people
crazy people but I like tight you know I
believe I truly believe that those
people are the minority the vast
minority I agree with you and I said
this I said this on a podcast interview
someone's like oh there's a police
extremist out there no it's like you
know what I travel the country all the
time I work with businesses of all sizes
oh yeah this has been Shapiro's podcast
I I travel the country I'm all over the
place all the time I work with all these
companies I I work
with frontline troops I work with the
mid-level leaders I work with CEOs I
work with everyone in the spectrum and
and I don't meet people regularly that
are like that I don't know who those
people are that are going crazy on
phaser I don't meet them I know they're
out there yeah but yes you're right and
I agree with you
most people what are they trying to do
with their life oh they're trying to
earn money they're trying is their
family they're trying to spend time with
their family they're trying to pay off
their house like that's what they're
doing so yes I agree that I think I will
kind of retract my statement a little
bit in saying that you say it's
sickening to the American public I think
most people in the American public are
definitely sick of it and that's what I
said to Ben Shapiro said Ben I mean he
is at he is at what is it called he's at
Ground Zero yeah for political fire yeah
and and you know I was on another guy
named Brian compliments podcast and he's
like the other end of the spectrum and
actually we joked about the fact you
know it's like if you met Mitch Berger
you'd like him fine he's a really nice
guy yeah and Brian Copeland everybody
that that's cool that makes sense but
they're completely opposite ends of the
of the political spectrum but I think
that those people at the far far ends
and both those guys can be a little bit
of ground zero for you know impact and
people guilt going crazy yeah there's
people that like to just stir things up
right I mean there's people that like to
stir things most people are like to stir
things up in one way or another
not necessarily politically specifically
some people literally but in one way or
in an audience it's fun not to do it but
to see it happen there's some people
they like to take part you know all
right moving on with this this piece you
wrote the legislative branch the United
States government is comprised of 535
legislators many of them have begun
venturing down a path that can only be
characterized as the opposite of true
leadership a path that displays a lack
of respect for anyone with a different
world view from them a path that
involves dehumanizing and demonizing
people simply because they are a member
of an opposing party many of these
legislators
stopped viewing people as individuals
and have instead applied a group
identity and used it to apply group
blame yeah that's a Jordan Peterson line
that I kind of stole I heard him say
that one time I thought was a really
good line well the the that is a true
statement
yeah and notice I said many I didn't say
all or anything like that either because
it's kind of what we were talking about
just now maybe sometimes you only think
that the vast majority of people are
doing it because they you only hear
about the people there that are being
you know kind of naughty or whatever so
yeah so it can be it may be a can be
said that maybe it's the minority of
legislators that are you know kind of
under going on to this kind of behavior
mm-hmm
but I think it's there's a trend
starting to have a more more and more
and more it's it's happening yes oh you
also again you also get the mob
mentality just a straight-up mob
mentality where it's blood in the water
and the Sharks are gonna go crazy and
who was it it was um Dave Chappelle oh I
saw a little clip of Dave Chappelle's
new Netflix special and he's making this
joke he says he says guess who I am and
if you do something wrong ever in your
life and I find out about it I don't
care if it's in five years 10 years 15
years 20 years if I find out about it
I'm gonna ruin everything you have and
he says guess who I am and people are
yelling out different names he goes um
you know what everyone does that's what
everyone does nowadays so we get this
mob mentality of oh you made a mistake
or you said something that was out of
line or whatever the case may be cool
we're gonna crucify you now that's well
that's so that's what's gonna happen and
unfortunately in Congress anyway they're
all kind of peers they're all kind of
equals so there's no one leader that can
kind of come in like Adam Eli massacre
and put it put a stop to things so yeah
there's there's no way that that can
really step forward and do that yeah is
that kind of influence unless you just
take the moral high
and people start to see that that's the
correct example yes you have to start
leading yeah laterally and I think like
Dan Crenshaw is doing a great job of
that he yeah he is just response he's
not emotional he just kind of you know
states his opinion recognizes that
there's other views tries to explain
around it doesn't get personal with
people he's just doing a great job from
that perspective yeah doesn't get fired
up no face just keeps normal face all
the time he's not getting crazy and and
you know it's it's hard I remember
explaining this when we got home from
Ramadi you know there was in inside the
seal community there were some people
that were looking at the operations we
did and what we did that thought oh wow
you guys going out in the daytime why
were you guys supporting conventional
operations they're asking these
questions and and basically it's it's my
fault but they were asking those
questions because it means that I didn't
do a good job of letting the community
know why exactly we were in that
position what the strategic impact of
those missions were and all those things
but I remember talking to lathe and Seth
cuz I mean coming home from Ramadi you
know we suffered some significant
casualties and to hear someone say you
know what were you guys even doing it's
real easy to get emotional and I sat
those guys down I'm like listen when you
discuss this with people if you get
emotional your your argument goes out
the window because now you're just
they're looking at you going oh he's
super emotional that's the only reason
he he's he it doesn't make any sense
we can't listen to what he's saying cuz
he's emotional yeah and so I said when
you when we talk about this with people
we have to just get unemotional just
detach and just explain hey this is what
we were doing here's what was going on
so what the conventional force we're
doing this is what the strategy was
here's how we were able to help you just
have to do it like that because if you
go what are you talking and another
thing that's really easy to do is you
already but they're like you get really
fired up and we can't do that so I think
Dan is doing a good job of that and
hopefully that example will continue to
spread and I know you'll you'll be doing
that as well all right moving down the
path leads to an end point of limited to
no effective communication a lack of
communication produces
environment in which no meaningful work
could get accomplished a worthless
environment in Congress means that
America will stagnate the process and
systems on which our country runs will
not be able to improve the result is
that Americans will suffer yeah people
can't even talk people can't even talk
to each other yeah in Congress yet if
you can't come by the way it's crazy
thick you can't the the fact of the
matter is that the vast majority of the
time it's gonna be you know close to 50
percent Democrat 50 percent Republican
and you rely on these other people to
pass legislation and to do the job of
Congress which is to pass bills that can
improve America improves the lives of
Americans so if people can't communicate
so I could have I could go into the
committee or whatever with a cure for
cancer like this bill will cure cancer
guaranteed even if it is you know what I
said before where you don't know I know
for sure mm-hmm this will cure cancer
but I go into committee that day the
week before you know representative
Charles I went on Twitter and I said
what this guy's stupid you know I just
did a tweet like that he's the cancer
not voting for it all his friends aren't
voting for it because they're on his
team
so that cancer bill it's even though
it's gonna cure cancer is gonna be the
best thing ever doesn't see the light of
day so it's like you might as well not
even have it continue on buck there is
hope despite them getting next to no
coverage in the media there are true
leaders in Congress we can learn from
their example a true leader recognizes
that every person comes for a unique set
of experiences including their
upbringing education struggles and
environment that forms their world view
including values priorities and
perspectives the leader also recognizes
that even if an individual's an
individual person's worldview is wholly
opposite than that of leaders it is
nevertheless equally valid and worthy of
consideration the leader knows that the
world view and the
person must be shown respect the leader
gives the other person the benefit of
believing that they have good intention
and thoughtful now and thoughtfully
analyzes their ideas before coming to a
conclusion as to their viability I gave
an answer I think is that the last
muster somebody asks this big crazy
question about leadership what are you
doing that's my and and I said oh you
know you do with that and and one of the
most underutilized tools in all of
leadership is to listen actually listen
to what other people are saying actually
listen to the people below you in the
chain of command listen to people above
you in the chain of command listen to
your if you're in a family Lifton's
listen to what your wife listen to what
you'll actually listen to what people
have to say and that's what you're
saying right here instead of as soon as
your mouth opens up I already am judging
what I think you're gonna say and
shutting it down is that I actually
listen I always when I'm listening to
people I always think why I don't I
don't my my first instinct when you
start saying something isn't why are you
wrong my instinct is hey what does this
person know that I might not know what
what is it what what about this person's
perspective is correct that that doesn't
make sense to me or that I don't
understand continuing on a true leader
of Congress recognizes that America
relies on the teamwork of people with
opposing viewpoints the idea of a
republic is not to have 51% of the
people creme and idea around the throats
of 49% of the people nor is it the
opposite it is to find solutions that as
many people as possible can be happy
with when they go to bed at night the
leader knows that the only way to
achieve this is through working together
and I think that's you'd think that that
was a common-sense statement
hey somewhere there's a happy medium
that will work for a majority of the
people Yeah right it's not way over here
and it's not way over here there's a
little dichotomy between those times
that you have to balance as a leader
yeah anymore it's like everybody on the
other side don't move an inch
don't give up an inch yeah it's like
this country was founded on something
called the Great Compromise yeah back
you know but they were right in the
Constitution yeah well that idea of that
every single thing is a slippery slope
is something that's very hard to contend
with yeah right and I think the reason
it's so hard to contend with is that
folks on the extremes are so ravenous
that when they do get an inch they go
cool we got an inch we need to take a
foot and we got a foot and I will take a
yard and so both sides have that
attitude yeah instead of someone coming
to the table putting there you go in
check and saying okay you know what we
trust that you'll do this and you know I
I think one of the things that makes
America stable is that it's a tough it's
a big bureaucratic system that's all
move right it's a big bureaucratic
system that's hard to move no one person
has a massive effect they just don't
yeah I mean like you can steer some
stuff you can make some things happen
you can make some put some laws into
place but those laws might get repealed
I mean it's a hard place to move around
mm-hmm and if people understood how hard
it is to move around then maybe they can
start to look into other viewpoints a
little bit more like let's fight let's
actually move forward yeah in some
direction that teamwork relies in turn
on communication between these people
the leader knows the leader knows how to
effectively communicate with both people
that agree with them and those that
don't they communicate directly with the
person they explain their side and
genuinely attempt to understand the
other persons with humility with respect
without insults they don't sling mud in
the public space effectively forever
alienating that person on whom they rely
for teamwork a true leader act
selflessly in the performance of their
duties they make the decisions and
implement the act the actions that they
truthfully think are the best in the
best interest of the people they
represent and of America they do so even
if the result is damaging to their
career they don't care about notoriety
and are happy to happy in the simple
knowledge that the people that do know
them believe
them wholeheartedly and they are making
a difference the good news is that we
have leaders like this throughout our
country
some are in Congress but if America is
going to continue to be the greatest
country on Earth
Congress needs more yeah
pretty straightforward yeah I mean we
need people to step up and that's you
know we talked about it before that's
why I've decided to do it you somebody
has to be the one to enter into the
arena and it's better to have somebody
that has this kind of attitude and I
think then allow somebody else to do it
and I think something those people with
this attitude are going to be able to
need to prevail
and we need to move away from the
extremist viewpoints that come out even
in Congress because it you know it's a
it's a it's a tough question will the
want the when you say that you look at
the other people as if their intentions
are good right yeah then you look into
someone else to go hey look what they
want is what's best for America and
that's a very pure way to look at it I
will tell you that I've talked to some
smart people that look at some people in
politics and say they have and I've
discussed this on a podcast trying to
think of with who but there's people
that think no they don't actually want
the best for America or their vision of
America is is different and outside what
what the Constitution says yeah
so there so that's another thing to
think about and I think that this this
attitude of people going into Congress
that will actually listen well this is
what I think will happen the people that
will go into Congress that actually
listen that actually can have meaningful
conversations I think that or my hope is
that that attitude will begin to rise
to the surface that people realize that
what you want you know the the very
first podcast I interview I ever did was
with Tim Ferriss and he asked something
about leadership then I talked about
humility and then I talked about being
balanced and I think what people
hopefully in America will start to
realize is that what we want is not are
not people on the extremes but people
that are balanced and can communicate
and listen which is what you are
bringing to the table
yeah and the reason that a lot of the
times people get elected that have these
kind of extreme views is because it gets
coverage it gets their name out there
people find out who they are and what
they're saying kind of scares the person
and the person is kind of reacting you
know from that fear and so I think you
know that I have a little bit of an
advantage here where I can be kind of
with this attitude and I can still get
coverage because you know I am a wounded
veteran and I've done so much service
and I've done all these things that I've
done so people are more likely to want
to you know tell my story because you
know it's a relatively compelling story
it's a very composed arouse talking to
Travis Mills the other day and
unfortunate we didn't have time to do a
podcast but we were talking about stuff
and I was like well you know you have a
great story and it's the same thing I
feel like saying to you like man you
you've got a good story right you got a
great story and you think well and I
said to find halfway through this
conversation with Travis I'm like hey
bro I just want to let you know like I
get that it's not exactly your great
story you know you got blown up and lost
both your legs and both your arms and
even same thing with you like hey and
you're saying it to you like hey I've
got a good story and it's like okay I
just want to let everyone know I get
that losing both your legs in
Afghanistan is not exactly a good story
however what you've done with it has
you've taken what would be in many cases
a horrible story yeah and you actually
truly have turned it into a good story
which is exactly what which is exactly
what Travis does well it's a good story
overall with a really bad inciting
incident yeah and so that's what it is
you know the whole story isn't that one
a it's what happens afterwards and so
that's the story but there yeah that
doesn't mean there's bad there's not bad
things in that story but overall you
know it's probably I don't know how
Travis feels maybe I'll ask him if I
ever meet him but if you asked me if I
went back in time and you asked me a
week after I got hurt or a couple of
hours after I got hurt or whatever
whenever I woke up you know would you go
back in time and not step on that ID I'd
say oh definitely I go I just say let's
not even go through this area let's go
around but you know I'm in my house now
and you know here's a big announcement
we got a baby on the way me and Pam oh
yeah thank you
so we have a baby coming there's the
real announcement yeah there's the real
announcement I should have said that
earlier a little boy due in February and
we got this nice house I have a great
life you know I think about that and if
somebody asked me right now if you asked
me if I would go back in time and not
step in the IDBI hell no I would step on
that I Edie a thousand times to be where
I am today and I think that's important
to remember about you know so what is a
good story if you can have that attitude
at the end of it that's a good story
there's no doubt about that man dang you
know as we were talking about leadership
and I was reading through some of the
stuff you've written I could not help
myself but to refer back to the United
States Marine Corps leadership traits of
course and and these traits are
originally I think I think the first
place that I saw is in the Marine Corps
warfighting publication six tackle Evan
which is called leading Marines and it's
in a bunch of other they quote this all
the time yeah they quote this all the
time the the particular comments that I
have around it here came from the
commander's leadership handbook which
was came out as a Marine Corps
publication it's not an it's not an
official publication but it's something
that they put out in 2016 and they made
some comments around around the
US Marine Corps leadership traits JJ did
ty buckle right what's that called when
you do that is it called the second I'm
gonna oh yeah it's an acronym I guess
but it's also an easy way to remember
things so they got these they got these
certain words that's what it spells out
it spells out JJ did ty buckle I bet
it's a buckle that has all the brass
probably first one is justice practice
being fair and consistent based rewards
and Punishment on merit straightforward
fair and consistent judgment and this is
this is again as I was thinking about
these thinking about you thinking about
where you're going think about what your
attitude is here's what they say about
judgment consider all sides of an issue
before making a decision
gee what a what a shocking idea yeah
that we would actually consider all
sides of an issue before making decision
and as a leader clearly that's something
it's interesting right you think to
yourself judgment means I make good
decisions that's what judgment means I
have good judgment
but what they're saying is judgment is
you actually just consider the different
angles before you make a decision
they're talking about how you come to
that decision yeah yeah and how do you
come to that decision by listening yeah
that's how you come to that decision
dependability here's a good one be on
time never make your Marines wait on you
what a stroke of leadership genius that
is never let your never make your
Marines wait on you and and that is
something that you see with leaders as
they get advanced as they get promoted
and all of a sudden they don't think
they need to be on time anymore they
think that everyone is there waiting for
them and that is just a horrible example
to set be dependable meet deadlines
ensure paperwork is processed
efficiently and effectively in order to
best care for your Marines we're here to
take care of our Marines and again you
take this and you apply this to your
attitude going into Congress what are
you there for to take care of your
constituents yeah and there
me to do that so I have to be dependable
to them if they had to double-check my
work all the time you know that's kind
of the the whole purpose of a
representative you know governmental
system is that we're trusting we're
depending upon this one person to
represent our you know our issues and
what we need and so if they had to be
double checking me all the time then
they might as well just think they're
not gonna have any time it's a full-time
job to figure out all the different
stuff about all these issues and figure
out what to do and go in and vote and
all this things so they wouldn't be able
to work they just everybody would just
be a representative and nobody would
ever get anything done besides running
the government without not work yeah but
we have to depend we have to depend on
that person next up integrity the most
important ingredient of leadership tell
the truth to both your superiors and
your Marines there you go we talked
about truths already always use your
authority for mission accomplishment not
for personal gain that would be a big
one to run across the entire United
States government how much how many
people do things for their personal gain
and not for yeah you wonder the good of
the country
you wonder how how many people are just
concerned about having a political
career and I'll say right now I'm
willing to sacrifice any kind of
political career and do the right thing
you know I'll find something else if
that's what it takes I'll run 50
marathons next one's decisiveness study
your alternatives and and take the best
possible course of action no win not to
know win not to step in and make a
decision mmm that's an interesting one
from leadership perspective I got a new
book coming out in January 2020 and I
talk a lot about not a lot but there's a
couple sections in there where I talk
about how to know when to step up and
lead and I got went into some pretty
good detail and it's really cool for me
to write this stuff because I get to sit
there from a detached perspective and
think of all these situations that I've
been in how I would handle them but one
of them is when when there's a little
bit of a leadership vacuum when do you
step in
and I went into this pretty big
explanation of okay well obviously
there's a leadership vacuum and there's
like a emergency situation and you see
that vacuum you step in there
immediately but and this is as I would
think about how I would actually do this
if there's a leadership vacuum but
there's no critical emergency
my first instinct isn't just a step
right in immediately because I'm gonna
let that thing develop a little bit I'm
gonna see if somebody else I'm actually
hoping one of my subordinates steps into
that leadership vacuum and then I get to
stay detached and I get to watch what
the decisions they're making and see
what the direction it's all good and
then I talked about what happens if two
people step into that leadership vacuum
at the same time what do you do what if
I step into the leadership vacuum and so
does echo Charles at the same time we
step into that leadership vacuum what do
I do
can you guess what I do echo Charles let
me lead yes I immediately go you know if
you and I both say I say go left you say
go right you right at that moment I say
go left you say go right I go Hey all
right echo we're going with your plan
I'm immediately gonna do that I mean
considering that there's no major
catastrophic incident if if if somebody
steps up and take lead I'm happy to
follow especially if it's my subordinate
cuz now as soon as echoes now is going
to take that problem he's gonna run with
it I can look around and see what else I
see what else is going on look at the
bigger picture
so yeah it's interesting when you look
at these leadership vacuums and how you
actually handle them the other thing I
talked about is this this is getting
detailed but if we're in a situation
let's say we're in a platoon and and
there's a leadership vacuum and I
immediately try and jump into the
leadership vacuum as soon as I see it
guess what not everyone else saw that
vacuum not everyone else felt it and
there's people there's gonna be some
resistance to you changing course right
now if I left that situation develop for
eight more seconds six more seconds
twenty more seconds whatever whatever it
is where all of a sudden people go wait
a second there's a leadership vacuum
meanwhile I'm sitting detached and I'm
going as soon as I this is the moments
right I'm making a call and now everyone
is waiting for the call they're waiting
to be led and by the way the decision
that I'm about to make i've already
assessed that it's a good call so
there's all these little
things to think about when it comes to
being decisive and another thing I say
is be is make your decisions as as as
late as possible which is a little bit
weird right it sounds counterintuitive
no you just make a call immediately no
actually I'll make up this is what I say
I will make the smallest decision I need
to make heading in the right direction
of what I think the broader decision
that needs to be made is so I want just
to meet you safe flank left no the first
thing I'm gonna say is ok get online put
some of machine-gunners over the left we
think we're moving that way but I'm not
going there yet mm-hmm
so this idea of being decisive it's got
a lot of little nuance to it that you
need to think about next one tact talk
with your Marines not at them that's a
good idea with your constituents right
treat others as you would like to be
treated
be steadfast during crisis stay calm and
steer your command in stormy weather
when reacting to bad news know that
initial reports are nearly always wrong
and then they throw this out listen
first and I had I think I read a
different one because I have some quotes
down here but there's all kinds of the
Marines they have all kinds of different
and not just not just official Marines
but just people human beings well the
one that I read had a picture of chesty
puller on it so I think that's probably
the most official solid but the one of
the quotes for tact that I liked from
from the one that I read is this
deference must be extended under all
conditions regardless of true feelings
yes so I could hate I could sit across a
table and hate physically hate another
legislator hate everything they stand
for hate their soul but I'm gonna sit
there I'm gonna listen to them so okay
that's a good that's a good point
yep I'm not gonna go on Twitter yeah you
and you actually are listening to yeah
well yes actually I even just playing
the game like oh girl it's got to do
this no it's like I'm actually listening
to what you're saying I actually want to
prove myself wrong yeah absolutely I
want to be wrong I want to I want you to
be right cause it how much how much
easier is my life if you and I want to
get a project done you have a way of
doing it and I have way of doing it how
much easier and better is it for me if
way it works better than mine yeah it
makes my whole life ease I go okay cool
I got you got my support one-percenter
you you know yeah I know you're voting
for you and as long as it's a good
playing guess what I get to vote for you
too and I'm happy yeah as opposed to me
having to argue and try and pry your
vote from you to me to do the project
the way I said yeah that's already I
already wasted hours if not days if you
come up with a decent enough plan
brahmanda Lord yeah and then even at the
end you can you honestly consider what
they said and then your assessment is
this person's that's the dumbest idea
I've ever heard you don't say so Thomas
idea I've ever heard ever gonna work you
say okay all right well I don't know
maybe that might not be ya know I would
go with it well what can you consider
this yeah you don't you don't just like
you act tactfully yes detect initiative
take action even in the absence of
orders from a superior be a self-starter
plan ahead and have three hip-pocket
plans for contingencies always look to
improve learn from your mistakes
initiative endurance
I actually was laughing when I read read
about it muscle to write yeah I think
we'll be okay with endurance maintain
mental and physical stamina know when to
recharge
most people who quit do not give up at
the bottom of the mountain they stop
halfway up it so endurance as I said I
don't think we need to even I think you
I think you will be the premier
endurance person in Congress clearly
I'll be come bearing set the example by
maintaining high standards and
appearance and personal conduct avoid
the use of profanity how you like that
echo Charles I'm fine with it at the end
of the day yeah be professional develop
gentlemen and ladies and future citizen
have you heard there's been some up some
pretty high-profile politicians that
have dropped some language it gets like
immediate press yeah I see if you drop
the f-bomb
I'm on national television you're gonna
get some coverage may not be good may
not be bad I don't know you can omit
yeah I think one of this general mattis
recently is a great obviously he's a
great example for all of these yes
especially lately for this because he
came out with his book and he's
constantly being you know picked at by
people that are doing interviews like
say something about trumps he isn't
about trumpet and he's come out so many
times saying I'm not going to comment
about a sitting president they just keep
asking again they asked in a different
way they asked in a different way and
he's just he maintains his bearing yeah
he does indeed unselfishness care for
your Marines above yourself boom
once again that goes back to your
constituents yeah taking care of your
constituents not and you just said you
know it's not about your political
career take every action to provide for
the well for your Marines they always
come first
courage take measured risk in combat and
peace act calmly and firmly in stressful
situations stand up for what is right
regardless of what others think accept
personal responsibility for your orders
and for your mistakes
I think they should actually call that
something else like extreme owners I've
written even in the face of popular
disfavor what you're doing so you have
to do it even when if you know that it's
if you believe that it's the right thing
to do no matter how many people are
telling you it's the wrong thing you
have to have to have the courage you
know to stand out from the group and put
yourself out there and what makes that
work
what makes that not an extreme is the
fact that has to be balanced with the
humility to listen to other people right
because if I'm just saying well you know
I this is what I believe and I'm
sticking with it but I'm not listening
anyone else that's a problem yeah if I'm
listening to people but I'm coming up
with my judgment and my judgment is the
same and I'm listening to more people
and people are telling me no that's you
shouldn't do it that way it's gonna lose
your next election but you believe it's
the right thing to do you do it that's
courage mm-hmm
correct Marines when required that's
that's a good one cuz you would think
you would think that that's so easy in
the military you know you somebody steps
out of line you just straighten them out
so I mean it's it's kind of interesting
because I in the SEAL Teams I know
that's hard it's interesting that the
Marine Corps finds that hard as well
because the Marine Corps more rank
sensitive right the SEAL Teams is not
ranked sensitive it's basically of open
you know it's almost completely and not
not completely open but it's definitely
more open the Marine Corps trust me but
you would think that in the Marine Corps
hey
lance corporal is doing something stupid
you're just gonna straighten him out
immediately and that's true to some
extent but you get to hey you you know
you got somebody maybe that's your peer
that's doing something wrong are you
gonna say something and it becomes a lot
more challenging allows subordinates to
make decisions yeah that takes courage
as well
knowledge works work towards technical
tactical administrative excellence read
study think write and teach think about
that read study think write and teach
those things are so underrated read
study think write and teach it actually
I think think it should go forth no it
should go last because all those other
things allow you to think those are
things that make you think if you want
if you read something you have to think
about if you study something you think
about it even when you write out your
thoughts or even talk about your
thoughts that's gonna that's gonna make
you think and it's gonna make you hone
those thoughts and teaching them
absolutely will do that you learn that
in jiu-jitsu the more you teach those
moves the better you get at them
loyalty display faithfulness to your
country the core to your unit to your
seniors to your subordinates and to your
peers defend your Marines against unfair
treatment display enthusiasm in carrying
out an order even if you may
privately disagree now here's where I
gotta you know we're gonna talk about
that one a little bit because if I
privately disagree and it's relatively
minor cool we're gonna carry it out the
more alls I'm saying is that you reach
to a point you you can reach a point
where if you're telling me to do
something that makes no sense whatsoever
it's gonna get people killed or it's
immoral illegal or unethical I'm not
gonna carry it out yeah
there's a whole there's a whole there's
a whole just gray area around that one
because if sometimes if you don't carry
it out you're gonna get fired and now
you don't have any influence anymore
which is not which is possibly not a
good outcome yeah so enthusiasm I don't
think I don't think this is another one
I think you just win that category well
I wrote this one down is I wrote one my
one note underneath it was belief based
on what I read it's just you have to
believe that what you're doing is
possible even if you think it may be
there's not a great likelihood like I
believed that when I was going through a
danger area looking for IEDs that I
would get to the other side you know
uninjured and I had to have that belief
in order to be able to do it I had to
believe that there was at least a small
chance that I could run 31 back-to-back
marathons if I didn't believe it at all
I would ran one and then just be like I
quit so and then you know in Congress
you have to believe that you can make a
difference you have to believe that you
can you know convince this other person
or learn something from that other
person that will convince you you have
to actually believe that so that's kind
of how I interpreted the enthusiasm one
yeah and like I said I think you're I
think I think endurance and enthusiasm I
think anyone have a hard time sort of
stepping up to the plate with you in
those respects and then that that wraps
up you know these leadership traits from
the Marine Corps and you know it's
probably a pretty good place to
what we're you know this this podcast
except for one more thing and this
that's we talked a lot about what you're
doing right now um people are gonna want
to support you mm-hmm because they
listen to podcast they're Patriots they
want to have reasonable human beings
running the government not crazy people
so what's the best way to for everyone
to support what you're doing to get you
the the the funds that you need the
support that you need how do we do that
yeah well you know there's a lot of
different ways you kind of were in a
difficult period you know in our country
and we have what we were talking about
with the poison is slowly making its way
into the government and feeding out into
the society and it's kind of breaking
apart you know the glue that holds us
together and so we do need to make sure
that you know a lot of people are gonna
I know that a lot of a lot of people
that listen this podcast I'm not going
to directly represent them in Virginia
ten which is you know bit in Northern
Virginia but we have you know everybody
knows that there were the decisions that
are made in the federal government they
were they affect everybody in some way
so I do think that we all have a
responsibility to make sure that the
correct people get elected in every
office and in every location and I truly
believe that I can be I have the JJ did
ty buckle attributes to be a person that
can go to Congress and and have a
positive effect I'm not gonna do it all
by myself I'm not gonna go in there and
be the one person that saves the world
or anything but I do think that I can
start taking it back in that that other
direction you know get what Dan crenshaw
get with Brian masse and form these you
know these coalition's that we can start
having a positive effect on on the way
things are going in Congress so there's
a couple different ways that people can
help they can you know there's
volunteering if you do live in my
district you can you can volunteer and
you can we will need people
to go out and knock on doors and pass
out stuff and make phone calls and that
kind of thing eventually you can just
tell people spread the word about you
know who I am and that I'm running but I
think the way that people can have the
greatest impact is what we were talking
about before and it is the fundraising
you know if I could I hate asking for
money and if I could fund this whole
thing myself if I had millions of
dollars then I would but you know I'm
from humble means I don't I simply don't
have you know I don't have the money and
use all myself
your wife's running the farm right now
right yeah Pam's running the farm and so
are you guys selling are you guys
selling food are you guys down to the
farmers market every Saturday and she
sells vegetables and she'll be selling
eggs soon so yeah you know we're how
many chickens you got we got 40 yeah man
we just started getting it
they just started laying eggs so we're
starting to get like seven eight eggs
now I only eat five every day so I can't
keep up with them but we're gonna start
selling eggs and then so yeah the farm
has really taken off for Pam and she's
you know obviously she's incredibly
supportive of what I'm doing and I
wouldn't be doing it without her support
yeah so we're worried you know we're a
humble family and you know I simply
don't have the money and we are talking
my you know the the current
representative she's raised over a
million dollars already just this year
because he has those apparatus in place
and she's the incumbent so she gets a
lot of support so we are talking about
that kind of dollar sign where it costs
millions of dollars to buy the
advertising on the TV on Facebook on
Instagram on Twitter and all these
different places by the road signs by
the Flyers you know buy cards all these
things it takes millions and millions of
dollars so you know if everybody that
listens to this podcast if you I know a
lot of people write in questions saying
when is Jawa know Jocko and Lafe gonna
start running for office you know
everybody asked that and hey listen the
hard fact is Jacko's not running for
office he's leading in a different way
and just as important way you know
leading in insist
Society and in business too and so he's
not running for office and Lafe isn't
running for office either but so this is
your opportunity here you've heard what
I think I've been on the podcast three
times I've read the books I am on board
with the extreme ownership mentality and
the attitude so this is an opportunity
for people that want to see somebody
that is bought into this in Congress
this is your opportunity to help make
that happen and so if you want to donate
you go to rob Jones for congress.com
slash donate and even if it's $1 $10
whatever I know you do you still get
around a million downloads per podcast
something like that yeah so let's say a
million people donate $1 that's a
million bucks that is huge that puts me
way way way far ahead in the game in the
game yeah and so that's the best way and
you know do it now as you're listening
to this just get on your phone and do it
right now it's it's it's pretty quick
don't make me like be like my friend
Frank and after five I have to chase
them over three times Frank you know
don't be frank and do it now and if you
really can't do it now set you know send
yourself of a notification so that you
remember or call your wife send your
voicemail and say hey remind me to
donate when I get home so you know take
ownership of that as well and so this is
your opportunity so that's the that's
the best way and that's gonna the way
that people can help the most
something I noticed yesterday that you
have so you had your Facebook your
Twitter your Instagram and your YouTube
and your old one used to be called Rob
Rob Jones journey Yeah right
and now that is that gone now that's
still there but now you have Rob Jones
for Congress and on Facebook you have at
Rob Jones VA on Twitter and Rob Jones
for Congress on the gram the grant Ellis
calls it so the reason that yeah I'm
trying to keep Rob Jones journey and the
political stuff separate cuz I know that
people that follow me on Rob Jones
journey don't necessarily want to see
political stuff all the time
so I'm trying to keep those two things
separate so that's why I have the
different handles for you know for this
project and yeah interesting call
I don't agree with it yeah it definitely
you know it'd be it'd be a bonus to have
the eight thousand you know Instagram
followers that I have all getting my you
know political stuff but I'm gonna do I
kind of want to make sure that I
maintain that that separation yeah so
that's another things just follow Rob
Jones follow me on all these things
smash the follow button sure awesome man
well that's that's like that's what we
got to do we got to give you some
support and get you the funds that you
need to make this happen
yes yeah like I said I hate asking for
money but it's the unfortunate part it's
the way the system works right now this
way you play the game works it's the way
you play the game and we play to win all
right
echo yes Rob we got Rob here obviously
he's you know on the path big-time on
multiple ways is there anything that we
need to do kind of get on the path on
our side can I bring up a few more
things like just a couple funny things
at the end now that we're gonna support
more in supports mode yes okay my first
thing this is directed directly at Echo
Charles sure you know how you guys were
talking you were doing the the the
Marine Corps
you know grading system for everybody
yeah what was the 174 eminently
qualified that what was the one below
that yeah anyway I'm sure a lot of
people have this problem where I'll be
listening to the podcast and you guys
will be talking about something and I
want to cut in to the podcast oh yeah oh
oh here's something funny that I could
say so I'm sure a lot of people have
that problem and the vast majority of
the time um listen to the pockets when
I'm working out or driving in the car or
something so I can't write it down but
this one stuck in my mind
and so it was when Eko Charles he was
talking about he said the expertly
qualified Mario player mm-hmm is the MA
is the man the person that can go
through the entire Super Mario game with
one guy mhm mhm
and I was out working on by the way
without warping yes and I just wanted to
bring up that the eminently qualified
Super Mario Brothers player would be the
people that can do the whole game one
guy in less than four minutes which is
in the world record yeah so hey that's a
good thought but they would you please
don't be robbed any money forget it
triggers I'm not gonna disagree I'll
agree but with additional stuff so I
wouldn't say that that would be the
standard because you can go okay I can
go for time for sure or I could go for
points and get all the coins I'm saying
then you could go I can go for time and
coins or time and that's insane so cuz
if you just go for coins you're not
killing everybody if you went for time
and coins yeah say yeah yeah but if you
went for time and points you're going
for coins killing everybody as fast as
you can so I think that might be there
well that's a good point
assume saying and maybe we'll let the
let the listeners decide and the thing
is I know that because I've tried that
for the time and I remember yet to break
the record I'm doing no I didn't do that
I did not break the record but I do
remember hey I didn't kill anybody I'd
skip so many coins which I usually get
because I care about how many Manahan
seemed saying get a hundred coins get an
extra man okay I'm saying yeah I don't
really I don't know how this ties in a
hundred percent but it does tie in some
percent so when we would be when I first
got in the team's we would do like
shooting competitions and you know you'd
have to run to this spot shoot here
shoot these number of targets run to a
different spot throw the put on the
rucksack drag it whatever you do this
stuff and then you shoot more targets
and if you miss the target it was like a
certain deduction right and there would
be somebody that would just go you know
what
they would figure it out in their head
that the shooting didn't really if the
person didn't set up the course
correctly I could just run through this
thing just dump Browns and win that is a
hundred percent and inflation and then
everyone would look at that guy that did
that mm-hmm and just think a loser right
just not eat to just hey I'm just gonna
I'm gonna win the technicality of this
game yeah but without without really
truly encompassing the spirit or
embracing the spirit of the game yes so
that would almost be like if you did
that you were gonna get shunned yeah
from the group yeah I can do Super Mario
Brothers doesn't have that spirit of
like killing everything you do it kind
of cuz you have to or you know it helps
you or whatever so I get the time thing
and four minutes I don't think you could
do all 32 levels in four minutes no they
usually use glitches in the game okay so
that's C is more defeating the dis
perience yeah yeah so I guess we're all
we're kind of on the level then right
yeah we are fully and so I guess and I
kind of get though to like okay you're
just gonna run through the course throw
rounds downrange and you don't care but
you're gonna win right Lucas yeah the
princess oh yeah you could look at it
and say you know what hey I won
whatever see the princess yeah but then
we get back to what we were talking
about earlier are you really gonna throw
your morals out the window just to get
the W no don't do that okay you you play
the game correctly yes my recommendation
okay so alright that's probably I will
off point that point number one okay the
next one is a story and I found it to be
interesting but stop me if you've
already heard it and there's a story
about an african-american boy when
Washington was crossing the delaware see
what's coming up to cross the Delaware
on Christmas Day and there were the an
african-american man and an
african-american son and he the the man
wanted to join the army to help General
Washington and the boy wanted to fight
as well but he was too yelling his about
11:00 General Washington said you're
you're too young but what you can do for
us you can stay back here on this
side of the river and you can mine the
horses and you can hold this lit you can
make sure that this Lantern stays a
light too to be it so that we know where
we can go they guide us back after the
after we win the battle and that night
they they went and they they won the
battle and it was a freezing cold night
and that little boy they came back he
had frozen to death but the lantern was
still lit and that little boy's name
Jocko so that's Tara that before well
you know I don't know I had not heard
that before you know have you ever seen
the little jockey yeah that's where I
saw that's yeah that I know that that
guy is called Jocko well that's the
legend they came in he is a little
african-american little jockey dude yeah
exactly
no apparently General Washington well
this is all you know legend or whatever
I don't know if it actually happened but
I know cuz this sounds like there could
be some urban like yeah to this office
so apparently we don't know if this is
true apparently General Washington he
had a memorial statue bill and that's
what the little jockey statue is and
then those statues were supposedly used
in the Underground Railroad to tell
people before they're safely okay so
that's that one okay and my last one
it's kind of serious because I actually
have beef John I have beef I know I know
so here's what happened we need to
squash it here's what happened uh moved
into a nice little town called
Middleburg actually I was having a house
built in Middleburg and earlier this
year was finally finished and while this
house is being built I was living in
Vienna Virginia and then Leesburg
Virginia which are all kind of around
Middleburg Virginia and after I went on
the podcast second time I was contacted
by a guy that I know and then you know I
think Eko Charles knows him his name is
Dave Burke good beauty it's contacted by
this gentleman and he said let's meet up
sometime
so I said okay where do you live he said
I live in Aldi
be Virginia and I went on that say oh
that's like five miles from where I live
where I'm gonna be living in Middleburg
and then like oh man all right I'm gonna
have a friend got a neighbor out in
Middleburg a neighbor have built a
neighbor then we build the house I'm
about to move in and I see a Facebook
post by this Dave Burke says that the
Burke's are moving I go you guys are
moving right what I'm moving in mmm and
Dave says yeah well you know Jocko had
this big opportunity for me out here in
San Diego so the beef is that Jaco stole
my friend dang friend and neighbor
stolen well if it makes you feel any
better which it probably won't when he
did announce to us or to me anyway that
he was coming to California I was fired
up too like how you weren't fired up I
was in verse you fired up opposites
manny moves out here moves up to
Carlsbad
yeah so it's like you know another one
of those deals men so think oh yeah
there's the thing last night I was here
originally me and Dave were gonna meet
up at Phil's yeah yeah and there was a
possibility there was a possibility that
you were gonna come yeah because Phil's
as we know is 200 meters from victory
MMA and physically it is it is possibly
my favorite oh it's definitely my
favorite barbecue now judgment I'm not
gonna play around Oh No yeah we can get
life going well no Whataburger would you
know no ladies got the song like oh he's
got another he's got a cop leaves got a
couple but you know for him being from
Texas anything like to even consider the
fact that a barbecue outside of Texas
could be your number one you you that is
that is blasphemy for life 100%
blasphemy so yes Phil's BBQ and I tell
you what Tim Kennedy came up and he
lives in Texas and I took him to Phil's
and I said hey Bros just stand by and he
had caught wait for like a photo shoot
or something and so he was all starving
and I took him over there and yeah
there's no denying it so when you you
said to me hey I'm gonna go out for
dinner with Dave burka can you go and I
was like it's you know depends you know
I said possible yeah and I actually knew
that it was probably not possible but
then I thought well if they're gonna
Phil's and I get done training and I can
go over there and get get it done in 35
to 40 minutes I was thinking maybe I'll
just go for it you make time for Phil's
yeah well let's say wouldn't it the net
loss because it's gonna take me it's
gonna take me you know 17 minutes to eat
anyways right yeah so would the net loss
is I probably won't want around 15
minutes total I'm just gonna order it
for you so it was ready I could have
rolled right in there that would have
been a game-changer yeah so cuz now
we're talking like a 12 minute scenario
yeah so I get in and Dave Burke calls me
and he says oh hey you know the the wife
and kids Whitney and the kids they
really want to see you too I'm like okay
yeah that's fair so I'll bring them to
Phil's yeah won't you come over to our
house okay yeah that'll where he said he
was moving to San Diego he didn't say so
I was like I'll cry just be a couple
minutes away
yeah like okay maybe joke okay so come
to that was love a good time
he was like all right cool so maybe you
can jump in uber and he said come on and
I look in the address that he gives me
in it's 45 minutes away yeah and I'm
like can you still come and jog was like
I'm praying that it's gonna say feels
but it says well Dave was nice enough to
invite us over to saw some like cool no
have a good night that being said super
up there yeah you were it up there in
the new bird home hmm
yeah you're gonna need a whole new slew
of donations just to cover the uber and
call us we'll sell some eggs well no you
can't yeah
I got to another speaking engagement or
something I'm gonna have to sell some
eggs yeah exactly
but to be fair the evening was very
pleasant and obviously Dave's family is
great and his wife made some great baked
ziti that we thoroughly enjoyed it was a
very fun evening but he did kind of
trick me here's the crazy thing so dave
was all fired up you know and I'm fired
up because Dave's like one of the best
people ever and he's moving up San Diego
you know and it's I'm super stoked and
then the Carlsbad word comes in a little
bit you know we're not quite you know
but here's the funny thing you know how
many times I've seen Dave since he moved
out here like three times I'm not even
kidding because he's on the road all the
time working I'm on the road all the
time working so it's cool that we've
seen each other three times but you know
it's not that cool hopefully I'll
improve over time yeah so those are
pretty good beefs any other other beefs
it's maybe even the squash you want to
hear something weird like when you tell
me you have beef with me I'm not kidding
like you thought him serious but like I
was like okay like I mean I got into did
you seem as Deval after his fight and
someone's like you know you have beef
with this guy he goes he goes no no I
don't have beef with if I had beef with
him I be waiting for him outside of his
house Mazda balls fight Mehdi ass good
but I thought that was legit when he
says no I don't have beef no if we had
beef I would be waiting outside of his
house that's what would be happening so
you and I don't have beef no we well
that was just a funny thing that was
when you said we had beef I was like oh
we're getting in a knife fight off the
trigger
yeah that's all my comments now we get
those those are good those are good
beefs
those are good good comments we're gonna
do some research about Jocko the plaster
lantern holder I am not sure what you
think you think it's urban legend or
real do you think there was a little
black kid holding the lantern for George
Washington that froze to death yes or no
fact or fiction yes
oh you're going with it yeah but well
put it the same it might not be exactly
that but I think it's like something but
that it's not nothing put it down it's
not just someone made up that story
really well but I have actually I have
actually I actually know this and I
cannot remember like I can't remember
sure not because it's so like at some
point why somebody told me that these
little statues were called Jacque when I
was like I wonder why that is and I
figured out where it came from but I
can't remember what the story is so it
could be true it could be not be true I
don't know yet we're gonna research it
yeah you know so I wouldn't be surprised
most likely case scenario in my head
right now
is that that story overall is true maybe
some details here and there maybe maybe
not true you know and it all sort of
ties in yes so we'll go with it in that
regard oh yes well that was just the one
of the vaguest it's not just like oh
here's a statue that means something
else you know some other thing but hmm
this will sound good if we make up this
story you know based on really like some
thinly veiled like element but here's
what concerns me I think if it was that
story that I had written read when I
researched it in the past it seems like
that would make the connection in my
neurons and I'd be like oh yeah that's
true yeah not quite there you know
feeling that not the feeling that full I
but but I you know you're you're subject
to your power of your memory yeah
there's a while ago that I research that
yeah buddy yes okay so we got beefs
settled yeah
we've got Dave Burke closed still you
know we're you know we're working
perk maybe when he yeah because you know
how lame I am yeah we know yeah yeah
when you call me and you're like hey you
know the fights are on you want to come
watch the fights and you live 17 minutes
from me I'm like oh I'll buy this not
watching like big thing yeah yes so yeah
when you're thinking 45 yeah so you
track me mini half-wit la let's face it
I'm half way to LA oh yeah you know it's
a really harsh review we really are
ready to say oh you only live halfway to
LA and then it's a there was an old
Saturday Night Live skit that was just
Californian people talking and all they
would talk about was the traffic like oh
you know morning how was the 405 this
morning oh my god it was a nightmare
and then the you know they just thought
that was one got jammed up right around
the you know exit 48 oh I'm glad I got
it you know yeah yeah
here you are halfway to LA can't even go
within 50 miles of LA all right the
struggle is real but hey like like you
like we all understand now we're
powering through it not much talk about
jujitsu this podcast in its direct form
and it's in direct form it was
everywhere
the spirit of jujitsu is everywhere yes
so that's the last time that we you came
here that we trained first time that was
the first time did you like it yeah I
did yeah it's good I actually have
jujitsu legs made I'm in my new schedule
I've gone and taken a couple Filipino
Kali lessons cuz I was taking those when
I was living in Salt Lake City grew so
now I'm making the transition to finding
you know the scheduling time where I can
go and find a good place to go and start
using my jujitsu lace I like it mm-hmm
put like hooks on those jujitsu legs
yeah yeah like my butterfly yeah yeah
yeah fully so being on the path
supporting others and ourselves were
doing jiu-jitsu highly recommended
required will say required already and
then let's go with it yeah I'm going
with it required some point required
anyway you're gonna need Aggie what kind
of gear we're gonna get we're gonna get
an origin game made in America 100% in
America the cotton that's grown to make
the fibers to make the material to make
the ghee mm-hmm the weave to make the
ghee all those different weaves 100%
made in America no compromise no
compromise compromise non zero is your
company 100% no compromise boom origin
main calmness we can get your gay
various levels of geez I don't even know
if their levels will just say options
this is not like one's not necessarily
better
they're just that's all matter of
opinion it's like when you you might
like you might like this Cadillac or you
might like that Cadillac Cadillac
they're both good cars all right hundred
percent yes but you might want one for a
certain reason instead of another one
you know to fit your lifestyle yeah all
right but you cannot only get keys there
cuz unfortunately not everyone does
train you to and unfortunately these are
not fully accepted as the garment to be
worn in all occasions at all times we
still have to wear other clothes
sometimes and one of those clothes that
we sometimes wear most often is
something called jeans yes sir in origin
makes jeans American denim same deal
same thing same thing from the time that
the atoms that form that grow right that
atoms are American yeah I don't know if
atoms grow well yes they rose right and
they have little American flags on those
because that's what we do you're right
yeah and and so yes we're talking about
patriotism Rob's a patriot robbed
servant guess what we're doing what
we're doing is trying to bring
manufacturing back to America we just
hired more people by the way we got more
people up at the factory up in Maine
because we're making boots now because
Americans need boots they need jeans so
yeah if you want to support the United
States of America if you want to bring
us back to the leaders of manufacturing
go to origin mein kampf get jeans get
keys get rash guards get t-shirts get
joggers if you are a jogger person if
you that is a good house a very
significant important disclaimer yes
because I'm not a jogger person yeah
you're not a lot to learn Duggars I look
really weird in joggers yeah so don't
don't get those if you're me yes
yeah but if you are interested in
maximum comfort and functionality -
let's be honest joggers when you
actually jog in them which I have like
twice you they function well they don't
fly around never ever ever the jog in a
pair of pants whatever yeah yeah like no
matter what yeah so you know okay you
know but yeah also supplements right
talk about support this is like actual
physical anatomical support you know
doing holes
see see you the whole deal you don't
think the fibers that support building
the atoms yeah or but well in this case
it on a vacuum yeah sure that too but
nonetheless these are we established the
fact that these are the most important
kind of supplements right there because
they keep you in the game mmm like I
always said before keep you in the game
yeah it's not something you're not what
it's like watering the roots rather than
watering the leaves you don't want to
leave don't unless you do water leaves
on it you don't any water the roots are
ruthless
exactly right so you want those roots to
be strong that's what super krill oil
joint warfare that's what these things
do they wanted the roots grow Harvey
also we got disciplined yes fair which
Dave Burke is a big supporter of he
takes discipline go capsules you know
get his mind right but guess what you
get this one in the powder out by the
way Andy Burke has been tripling up his
scoops and I rolled with him last night
again luckily that one wasn't on video
that video actually did the one of you
and Andy roll it was like just for like
three minutes was that like the end of
the round or something if yeah was
whatever was left on the round but yeah
that that was it actually uncanny
uncannily accurate depiction of rolling
with you it just felt like super heavy
and that's fazzy yeah real heavy and
just like heavy look we should read the
comments we should do a podcast we just
read comments I know you got that but
that had some funny comments yeah yeah
this you know you talk about political
haters and there were some so they were
hating on me they're hating on Andy
they've hated on jujitsu I mean most
people were super cool but the funny
ones the ones that would be worse like
comically reading were ones that you
know people that were just talking smack
Tom and yeah martial arts is one of
those trigger events you know like
martial arts diet raising kids jim
solitarily sleep apparently yeah like
how much you suing your brother actually
oh yeah speaking of discipline we got
new discipline it's in a can it's called
discipline go it is what I'm gonna call
clean energy right oh yeah you know you
got those energy that's that's not clean
or dirty energy it's called a drinks
with a bunch of sugar in them and other
chemicals this drink has not that in it
yeah it's like you it's clean and it
like you can't even call it an energy
let me let me read the ingredient list
filtered carbonated water natural flavor
citric acid monk fruit
oh did you hear that that's clean that
is as clean as you can make a drink and
you know why
you know what's revolutionary what's
revolutionary the way we're able to do
that is because we are pasteurizing this
like what they do with milk we are
pasteurizing it we're heating it to that
certain level killing all the bacteria
or whatever that's in there so we can
stay on the Shelf without putting a
bunch of chemicals which is what
everyone else does
so discipline go we got two flavors
right now we got more common and they're
all good well this was my mother line
well your topic thunder oh dang I
nothing yet and I'll tell you it's
called Tropic Thunder and sometimes you
know oh that's cool name whatever it was
either that or I had to call it what it
is and you want to know what it is yeah
pina colada pina colada let's face it
yeah that doesn't matter can't come out
with something called pina colada
no so we called the Tropic Thunder yeah
so you can get that discipline go cans
all that stuff from origin mein kampf
milk protein yes dessert in the protein
the form of a dessert and this work get
more protein in the form of dessert for
your kid and a snacks like a sweet snack
we'll say okay kids right yeah yeah it's
actually an amazing thing and then ice
what are you what are you drinking today
my my little thing down yeah you got
some chocolate white tea and I'm I have
never felt more matches mental faculties
or just fire find cylinders and you're a
tea drinker because your wife's from
England big tea drinker I'm actually
trying to create my own drink you know
how Arnold Palmer yeah you're a fan of
the all are appalling you like to put a
little shot of lemon let me tell you
what iced tea we have a little flavor
coming out for powdered disappointing
and a flavor come out for Discipline go
in the can and the name of the flavor is
Jaco Palmer
and I'm not even and I'll tell you what
it is the one that both of them they are
you liked are you like Arnold Palmer's
yeah so if you picture the best Arnold
Palmer that you ever had that's how good
these are I was like when I went through
whatever eight samples and like no
little more less more tea less that more
man finally got it
when week when I got the good one when I
got the final one I told belittle I'm
like hey go manufacture both these
things right now and I want this stuff
tomorrow and he's like it's gonna be six
weeks I'm what bro sent me more samples
alright so yes I'm trying to get my own
drink made or not made but I make it a
thing you know how when the first time I
was here we went and we had iced teas
and I put a little half-and-half in
their little hitter yeah
yeah so I I kind of got that from
learning how to drink tea from Pam Co
she introduced me to the way that
English people drink tea did were milk
and there's a little milk in there so I
came back I'm American we'd like to do
the iced tea my thumb thinking outside
of the box I'm gonna outside the box
think kertzer so I was like you know
what I'm gonna have an iced tea bring a
little half-and-half to pour that in
there delicious most people think a
little gross but what I'm gonna start
doing now I'm gonna start saying I'll
have a Rob Jones no see you at half see
what happen half in there I would have
been way more supportive of this if you
would have said oh so I'm gonna bring it
back a little bit so I put milk in there
vanilla milk cause let's face it that's
an option mm-hmm that's an option I have
tried that vanilla my have a bulk
I've tried protein powders like it okay
well regular to you haven't tried any
other that's right that's true yeah I'll
try but now you and I have at this
juncture it wouldn't be that wise to do
the mall thing yet because half-and-half
is gonna be a little bit more widespread
at this point seems saying yeah it's
trying to step in its role is
establishing the Rob Jones yeah like
half a now have my own betting that
everybody knows about
yeah so in a way is kind of up to you to
us to bolster the availability of a more
in a general way to make the milk Jones
oh yeah that's the next level one hey
that's a good yeah you know the
discipline the Arnold pop there Arnold
Palmer flavor which is called Jocko
Palmer it's so good alright so that's
that all Charlie white tea all milk blah
blah blah
yeah Czech origin mein kampf boom get it
yeah whatever you need whatever you like
also Jaco has a store it's called
Jacques Cousteau yeah so online store
yeah if you want to represent you go
Jocko store Komnas where you can get
your deaf core shirts come on let's face
it when you see someone representing the
it's good but yeah you get this money
equals free dogs t-shirts hoodies
lightweight and heavyweight hoodies by
the way trucker hat or flex fit Rob
Jones what is a flex fit it's the one
that fits in flicked Oh like the fade
caps yeah no no no they're fitted but
they stretch in there so do you know
yeah hey truckers bro yeah I have to go
but not by a wide margin apparently well
you know there's certain instances where
the the Flex might be better right your
ally think of any you're working out of
here the outside you're gonna be
sweating a lot I don't know but we're
not against possible flex fit I like
both yeah if I had to choose a very
political answer but here's the way the
rest of my life I'd go trucker there we
go thank you but here's the thing I
don't wear hats at all anymore are you
anticipating in this debate
Broca's when I used to wear hat what
made you stop I think he was like your
head yeah in the Sun yes
and you don't wear at no sir I don't
like I should because the fashion says
no his lack of hat lack of preparation
for the Hat it hottes and there you well
I think that I have a hat with me
everywhere I go yeah
I don't wear it all the time because I'm
not one of those guys what guys guys
already had all the time yeah I dig it
um I don't think about it if my head
isn't hot I don't think about it for
whatever reason jerk but nonetheless
okay we got both that's that's the good
news Rob Jones we have both lets me get
a good flex in your own decision yes sir
yeah you're good system that one you are
100% wrong and I am 100% right oh yes
sir better god and if you don't like
trucker hat you're evil you're a
communist Jocko store.com yes for you
communist or otherwise you know whatever
they don't come yes no communist allowed
No yeah but coming this won't represent
like that anyway see I'm saying so
you're just gonna dig in on what he
called I got a scroll yeah cool don't
forget to subscribe to this podcast
which apparently you haven't done yet
according to echo Charles you've
listened to hundred and everyone that I
knew whatever podcast and you didn't
subscribe according to echo Charles so
he says you should subscribe if you want
you go say if you wanted there so it's
like does that mean you don't have to
you know incorrect oh yeah you know it's
all optional really at the end of the
day also worry get podcasts subscribe to
that one mm-hmm my daughter has a
question for Uncle Jake by the way I
told her last night that uncle Jake
recommended strongly that she just
called him on FaceTime whatever since
she has the direct line she felt real
good I sent her a video today by the way
yeah yeah she sent me a video first okay
from Sara Charles's okay cool phone
she's bringing away the warrior kid to
school yeah show-and-tell
yes she's nice she sent me a little
video and bringing this book into school
thank you and then she was telling me a
little bit about the book and then I
said hey because she said she said
there's even a picture of you on the
back and I informed her that her dad
took that picture
Eko Charles that's really become the
meat of that book is that made that
photograph there yeah that's what I
thought a lot of people and I guess
there's some cool lessons or whatever
but yes you are right that picture yeah
warrior kid podcast we are in the
process of recording a couple right now
which is good I have a story in my brain
for the Uncle Jake story so we're
getting there so warrior Kip
gasps subscribe to that and also don't
forget about warrior kids soap we got
eight up in central California
speaking of farming lives on a farm is
oh it's awesome it is it is very much
totally legit so go to Irish Oaks Ranch
calm and that way you can stay clean
yeah
also a YouTube channel we do have a
youtube channel officially hey Rob Jones
has a Rob has a Rob Jones for Congress
YouTube channel as well I do you want to
forget about that yeah as you've written
some cool videos up there that's another
way to see the exactly like what kind of
videos so far Lee only long these notes
closer to see no explosions don't worry
we'll talk there's a real life explosion
oh yeah really cool their cameras out
during it's weird though makers and
people that have done there's people
that had a footage of everything like
some guys put the cameras on their
rifles yeah camera on the rifles on
their helmets there's videos of
everything nowadays I mean when when we
had Ron Chiron here who they like
assaulted this hill and he's a Medal of
Honor recipient the whole almost the
whole thing is on video it's on YouTube
you can watch it it's like and you watch
it and as bad as it sounds when you read
about it as bad as the situation sounds
when you read about it you're like I'm
thinking myself man this sounds
absolutely horrible you watch the video
and you go oh my god I mean I was laughs
I was I was laughing about it with him
these guys get out in the valley it's
not even a valley it's just it's a it's
a it's a ravine no it's it's a it's a
canyon yeah they get out at the bottom
of the canyon and assault up a hill a
freaking giant reinforced castle it's
like out of a out of a Prius or a
medieval movie and that's what they did
and like they didn't make it all the way
up because it was an impossible task but
yeah so there's there is video that's
why when you said oh there's this
explosion I remember watching that video
yesterday but yeah not the explosion and
not the the explosion but what um as far
as like videos or whatever
I'm gonna subscribe must smash the like
button all that stuff what what am I
gonna be watching um you're gonna be
watching stuff like that you get mostly
the videos that we're gonna be doing is
just getting people to know who I am
what I'm about so there might be some
personal stuff on there where I'm going
around the district and kind of talking
about oh you know well now this is where
I went to elementary school this is
where I used to go hiking on the
Appalachian Trail you know stuff like
that so just getting people to know what
I'm all about as a person so yeah
there's gonna be a lot of that stuff
going to deal if you need footage from
the podcasts you can take little clips
of your statements and stuff let echo
know you know there yeah you could edit
some of those yeah well yeah definitely
do that but yes we do have our YouTube
channel jump on us YouTube channel 3 it
interested in what Rob Jones looks like
if you don't know already which I think
you're gonna be sorely disappointed if
you want to know man
and then there's psychological warfare
it's a bunch of me in little short
recordings about how the decision that
you're about to make which is the wrong
decision that you know and you need a
little something to get you to make the
right decision psychological warfare
will get it done for you just press play
on your smartphone device yeah and you
will literally make the right decision
yeah what that does really and I know
literally is overuse but I'm saying you
will ferrell literally yeah make the
right decision it makes sense because
it's you talking about them almost
making a short third thing that we
covered on machete season when the first
thing the ret when a revolution happens
they take over the radio stations
because they want to get right into the
thoughts of the people right no you
don't read it you don't interpret
anything it's going into your brain it's
words mm-hmm that's a psychological
warfare it's going right into your brain
yeah but your words are saying hey right
now you're about to make a short-term
play let's just shuffle that butt over
to the long-term that's all we're gonna
do we're gonna make that decision but
instead of short-term gonna go long-term
that's all we're gonna do right now oh
well that's what we're gonna do and then
you go do it that's what it does yeah
effectively by the way you
yeah so you could do that you could put
a cure of the doll you're ever here to
cure the dawn a cure in the dunyah yeah
yeah
because you could just listen to a cure
the dawn tracks
sure eight minute tracks what's a music
in the background what this be talking
yes is that weird
mmm no people make it yeah I dig it I
dig it I like music in the back of
talking I like that yeah well that's
what the good video is and people love
that music a lot of people think it's
maybe what's get said but yeah most
people think it's just a video that made
that video cool that's what you've told
me a lot yeah I'm one of those people
for sure but you know all right if you
want visual reminders of saying on the
path go to flipside campus calm that's
Dakota Meyers company and he's making
really cool graphic designs including
two that just got released which are way
the warrior kid well ones way the
warrior kid the rules for the warrior
kid and then and then also a picture
Mikey
yeah heading out of the force to face
the Dragons designed by John Bozek
himself drawn by John Bozek himself so
check those out flipside campus comm
also on it on it fitness on it com+
chocolates where you can get your
kettlebells battle ropes rings highly
essential rings which I didn't know
before I know now hundred percent no
rings maces steel Mesa steel bells all
this stuff really good stuff on there
really good stuff on it calm slash got a
bunch of books got leadership strategy
into actors Field Manual I talked a
little bit about today you can pre-order
it right now if you want to get the
first a dish if you don't want to get
first edition just wait just wait with
everything that you do go down a path in
your life where you're just waiting for
everything and nothing ever happens do
that or order now and get to get the
first edition ISM also got way the
warrior Kid 3 where there's a will
that's also live you can get that one
immediately and there's the way the
warrior kid and marks mission those are
all available in the miking the dragons
that's the best kids book for ages under
6 sure
yes maybe even over 6 sometimes yeah
sometimes I was
things you forget about that and stuff
you saying and and it's kind of obvious
like being like afraid of something then
you say then somebody will be like hey
what are you really afraid of the above
thing I didn't really think about what
I'm really afraid just feel scared
whatever we had a little incident at the
Willing household two days ago yeah it
was time to go for an ocean swim with my
youngest daughter
there was a tide scenario that was
making it the only water entry was a
little cliff jump and my daughter my
daughter was hesitant at the moment of
truth how high not high at all depends
on where the waves were at and you had
to time it well and there's a lot of
let's say whitewater activity in the
zone which raised the fear level yes in
fact I asked her what are you afraid of
and she's like it looks like it's crazy
don't worry yeah yeah but we had a
little talk and I threw it I did I've
got to admit you know wait what was it
like the paint surprised throw you in or
they're like hey they don't learn you
have to make it I gave her I gave her
time to think about it actually part of
the reason that I gave her time to think
about it was I wanted I wanted her to
experience the fear for a longer amount
of time right not just like no we got to
do it right now let's go I wonder her
stand there and think about it because
that's actually the worst part yes and
so then fine I said listen I said she's
like I really don't want to it really
looks it looks like it could be really
dangerous it looks like I'm gonna get
sucked in those rocks and I said you're
not gonna get sucked into the rocks
you're gonna be fine and just so you
know you are going to do this so we can
wait as long as you want but this is
happening and when my kids know me like
when I say that it's not there's no
there's not it's gonna happen
and so I said that to her and she kind
of got the defeated look on her face
because she knew it was gonna happen and
the the little bit they didn't come out
what I could see in and my youngest
daughter she got these big big blue eyes
and she's real good with that whole play
oh she's good she my wife she would
break my wife down like a
i'ma just snap her around zero chance
when those she got those big eyes that
it can it can hold the tear well he does
hold it there which is even worse right
now hey guys so she started doing that
with me guess what I don't play that
just tears in the industry we call those
tears falling upon a heart of stone
yes so she started get work in that
angle I said don't even don't work that
angle it's happening we're going off
this cliff so we get so finally she's
different she looks defeated she knows
it's happening she walks the edge and I
said okay and it was it's kind of a
tight little promontory to try and jump
off just a little thing jutting out it's
actually not big enough for two people
so I kind of put her a little bit in
front of me and then I said okay we're
gonna go on three and I knew I couldn't
actually go with her because there's
certain rocks down there you gotta watch
out for so that I just kind of like okay
one two scooped her up grabbed her and
threw off you know the best thing she
hit the water she started swimming away
from the rock so she could be safe and
then I I got watched her and then and
then she looked up and she had a big
smile on her face but it's fun yeah and
then we swam you know whatever is back
around the point did it to the to the
beach well that's all good though and I
told her I said look that's what that
was that was Mike in the Dragons that
was that was you stood up and faced your
fears that was jumping off the bridge
for Mark where the warrior kid you just
did it that's what it's about but in
when you look at a big picture like
that's a specific cinema where you knew
her like capability and limitations or
whatever because sometimes like you get
someone maybe not comfortable in the
water or something like that
oh yeah that's and you throw them in oh
yeah they're you know they're not
looking back smiling they're traumatized
and now they can't go in the water at
all you more you know yeah I kind of did
that with one of my friends kids like
the dad is a good friend of mine he was
on unemployment you're not invited to my
house you know he was all gonna check it
out he was on deployment and so while
he's on deployment who guess who's
responsible for like making sure that
the Sun is kind of like you know legit
it's me
and
I didn't get to see him that much
because I was like working and deploying
and all that stuff so I finally saw him
at the beach and I was like cool we're
going in the water and he's like what
and I just picked him up and I hopped
him out in the surf zone he wasn't happy
the mom was crying she wasn't crying
when she definitely was like you know
how you know sometimes things are
unfolding and you can tell people
they're just doing their best just to
like detach from it yes she was in that
mode she's a good friend of mine she was
kind of like a look I know this guy's
probably yeah but he handled or was he
like I don't know if I can even hang
with jockle anymore it was probably not
the best it was probably not the best
move on my part I also did that one time
with a real little kid where I picked
this little kid up and I said you know
something there's a boy right and I said
something like oh there is and it's
really yeah it's just like always be
cute I was like yeah and he needs to get
used to you know things like machine-gun
fire go out and the kids started crying
because this kid was like 6 months older
maybe even a little bit young baby
so be careful with that well this all
had so you essentially and I'm trying to
gather like info so I can actually use
in the real world so you kind of you're
like on the on that would he call it on
the borderline of too rough right yes so
and I'm better now yeah better now yeah
he not to just totally go into like one
more little situation I was surfing with
my little daughter same one right and it
was we were done and there's cliffs you
got to climb up there to get out
carrying your board it's cliffs it's his
trails the whole nine yards and so what
I did was she's 10 years old
so I it can be hard and there's little
parts where you could possibly fall off
right yeah probably not though most
likely you're gonna be good even you
think about what you're doing so I get
done and I got my board so I run up to
the top of cliffs carry my board I put
it down and I turn around so I can go
help her carry her board for
yeah and I thought to myself if this was
my son when my son was that age there
was zero chance of me going down and
helping him zero yeah you figured out a
kid and so I stood there at the top and
I just watched her and she made it up
and when she got to the top I said you
know I was gonna come help you I said
but if that was your brother there's no
way I would have ever helped him and I
don't I would rather have you do it for
yourself what do you want me to do do
you want me to give you special
treatment
or do you want to be strong she's like I
want to be strong and I said cool we're
good yes so there yeah you can have a
tendency to lean especially when you've
got your baby kid right the youngest you
know yeah especially when they can make
those tears things there's a big giant
tear sitting on the edge of their
eyeballs thank you all right Saul you do
run that risk though of going like touch
you know sticking one toe over the
border indefinitely I'm making one kid
crust you can traumatize the kid you can
make them hate the water there's a lot
of things you can do so you got to be
careful on them you got to lean towards
and actually the best policy as you lean
towards whatever you do with them builds
their confidence doesn't break it yes
that that's the line you say oh if I
throw them in the water and they get
they get done with it like I actually
did it that builds their confidence cool
if you throw them in the water and now
it freaks them out and you broke their
confidence that's bad
so the line that you should be going for
is everything that you're doing with
your kids builds their confidence until
they become overconfident and then we
have to start putting them in check
that's when you take him for the pool
competency I did that with my son like
oh you're good okay cool
I tied his feet tied his feet together
tied his hands behind his back and I had
him do we call it drown proofing and the
first time he did it he did not pass
what age is this one I don't know he's
probably seven that's advanced for seven
he's good now but you know the first
time I had to I had to go for that right
little rest right and that's that thing
that you say to right where you're like
hey put them into a if they're like in a
leadership situation at work or whatever
right like you're like hey if they're
overconfident give them something just
beyond their level you know they're
under confident not kind of you give
them something then guess what this is
when my son was like starting to get
into big
waves and you know you can start if you
circuit an overconfident with the ocean
you go for the oceans gonna win you
Jenna
hmm so you don't want to let that happen
all right back to what we're doing here
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
that's available as well it's how you
stay on the path as an adult or as a kid
lots of kids all read in that book as
well the audio version is on iTunes
Amazon music and Google Play as an mp3
album with tracks and then finally we
got extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership books about leadership
that we experienced in combat that Rob
Jones is going to bring those principles
to the government with your help which
is out standing how many tweets do I get
in a day that says about whatever
politician on either side that says this
guy could use your book these people
could use your book they said all the
time send them to Congress they say I
would say well send them give me an
address
exelon front that's our leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership go to Ashland front comm for
details we got EF online which is
leadership training that you can do
virtually it's interactive there's
choose your own adventures
decision-making drills in there for
leaders go to EF online.com to check
that out we got the muster the next one
is in Sydney Sydney December 4th and 5th
we will be there who knows when we'll be
back in Australia in America the 2020
dates will be out soon so go to extreme
leadership com2 pay attention to that
and don't forget that all musters have
sold out and all musters will sell out
so we actually rearranged the room in
Denver because it sold out so fast we
like needed we bought more space and
maid got more seats but we can't do that
every time we maxed it out so if you
want to come go to extreme leadership
calm and then EF overwatch where we are
taking proven leaders I've got some
really good talking to Mike Cirelli we
got some candidates now that were not
candidates where we got some people that
were hired
and that of just giving the best
experience that but we're getting the
best referrals and feedback on the folks
that we're placing these are special
operations and combat aviation leaders
that are coming off the battlefield and
going into civilian companies and
helping them with their leadership and
helping them win communication it's
important we talked about that a decent
amount today if you want to communicate
with us then you can find us on the
interwebs on Twitter Instagram and on
even fuse and book echo is adequate
Charles I am at chocoholic Rob Jones
okay so Rob Jones for congress.com yeah
Facebook is at Rob Jones for Congress
Twitter is at Rob Jones VA right as in
Virginia right correct
there was Opie VA in Ramadi and it was
opv a it was it was Virginia okay but
you could have thought it was the VA
yeah exactly yeah I wanted to make it
Rob Jones for Congress but they don't
allow it to be that long for Twitter so
we had to shorten it got it Instagram
Rob Jones for Congress YouTube Rob Jones
for Congress Eko anything else
Thank You Rob Jones for coming again Rob
any final thoughts yeah you know I've
been lucky enough there have been kind
of three main influences in my life
external influences Marine Corps Jim
Jones which maybe we can talk about
someday as well I had a big impact me at
the right time finally you know extreme
ownership Jaco echo you know the the
podcast and everything and I've been
lucky enough to not only interact with
all three of those become a part of all
three of those befriend you know all
three of those you know I'm just I just
remain incredibly grateful that I've had
these opportunities so thanks for having
me on again looking forward to the next
time already well as you can imagine the
door's always open any time you want to
come on you know just knowing you here
in your story
getting to see the way that you were
operating out in the world I throw that
out there oh he's an inspiration you're
an inspiration bro I mean the fact of
what you've done what you continue to do
it's awesome and it's all it's you might
think it's cool to be here it's even
cooler for us for me to have you here
and and hang out and get to get to talk
to you and hang out with you so thank
you for coming back more important
thanks for the service and sacrifice
that you've made for our country and
that you continue to make and what
you're going to make in the future you
are a leader you are a warrior and thank
you and to the rest of our warriors out
there that are face to face with the
forces of darkness in the world thanks
to you all and to your families
for your service and your sacrifice and
here at home thanks to our police and
our law enforcement and our firefighters
and our paramedics and our EMTs and our
dispatchers and our correctional
officers and our Border Patrol and our
ice agents and our Secret Service and
all the first responders out there thank
you for protecting us here at home and
everyone else that's out there if you
think you've kind of you think you've
kind of maxed out on what you can do if
you think maybe it's time to back off
the gas pedal a little bit and relax if
you think you've given everything thing
that you can give right now well while
you're thinking that once you just take
a moment and think about Rob Jones think
about Rob Jones who's still going who's
still going strong despite everything
that life has thrown his way he's still
going no matter what he gets up and he
gets after it and I recommend that you
all do the same and until next time this
is Rob Jones and echo and Jocko
out